Aiaia! Aiaia!
Aiaia!
Oh
Teams hat wieder mal ein Sound verstellt
was ist da los?
gut was heisst das was ist da los das macht
Teams jedes mal weil Teams Absoluter Crap ist
und das übelste Shit aller
naja
aber wenn man ehrlich ist von den Alternativen
ist das immer noch das beste aber das heißt nicht
das es gut ist
aber hier Recording
aber hier das Schwarm stellt das immer um
Ich wollte das nur noch mal betonen, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind, ne?
Stream, yo, Semparu, Cutebot ist am Start.
Dankeschön für den Sub. 16 Monate, das ist aber schon richtig, aber sowas von.
Ja man, da am Start hier, der Magiyoyo ist da, SeriousMarx ist auch da, der Cutebot persönlich.
Ja Twitch hat es noch nicht so wirklich gecheckt, ich habe auch noch keine Ankündigung oder so
gesehen, aber jetzt habe ich geleakt, dass ich selbst gesuppt bin. Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn
man seine Tweets selbst liket, das mag ja auch keiner. Keg, Fekrus, nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Ne Chat, könnt ihr erzählen, was ihr wollt, das stimmt nicht.
Ich muss euch was geiles erzählen. Heute war wieder so eine Selbstfeierveranstaltung bei mir auf der
Arbeit, wir machen das ab und zu mal, aber ich glaube das kennt jeder selbst, egal ob ihr bei einem
kleinen Laden, mittleren Laden, großen Laden, international, ultra großen Laden arbeitet,
so Selbstfeierveranstaltungen hat jeder, hat jede Firma. Captain Zika, echt, ist das so kompliziert?
Zumindest wie gesagt, wir hatten wieder so eine schöne Selbstfeierveranstaltung heute und die
war etwas ungünstiges Timing, sage ich mal, diese Selbstfeierveranstaltung, weil, ich bleibe mal
kurz auf der Seite wegen Dark Theme, weil sie haben erst vor kurzem ein paar Leute rausgeschmissen. Ich
muss mal ehrlich sagen, so im Nachhinein betrachtet, wenn ich mir so angucke, welche Leute, ich kann es
nachvollziehen, teilweise, nicht bei allen, geh mal ICQ. Was, ICQ? Was mach ich besser, wenn der
Chat das sagt, dann mach ich das besser von meiner Lieblingskiste, wer weiß was für komische russische
Hacksor da am Start sind. Und jetzt, warum soll ich auf ICQ gehen? Es sieht, es ist new und es benutzt
wahrscheinlich immer noch keine Sau. ICQ in 2020, Alter, was ist was? Bot API, machen die jetzt
einen auf Homeoffice Konferenztool oder so, ICQ? Sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein Homeoffice
Konferenztool. Möchte gerne Teams Alternative. Was da wieder, das sieht wirklich aus wie ein
Teams-Klon mittlerweile, was da für Entwicklerressourcen wieder reinfließen, ohne jegliche Hoffnung auf
Erfolg. Schon der Wahnsinn. Sag mal so, was heißt ohne jeglichen Erfolg? Ich kann mir zumindest
nicht vorstellen, dass die Erfolg haben. Download, please. Soll ich mir das angucken? Ich meine,
es gibt es für Ubuntu. Soll ich mir das wirklich, Moment, Ubuntu bringt mir ja nichts. Soll ich
ernsthaft, ja, soll ich wirklich ICQ runterladen jetzt? Aho. Guck mal, das gibt es noch nicht mal im
User-Repo. Also wenn es schon was nicht im User-Repo gibt, dann ist es shit und keine... Okay,
für welche Sachen gibt es denn das? Windows? Es gibt es nur für Ubuntu. Ich habe gerade
kein... From SnapCraft, excellent. Na dann ist ja geil. Habe ich Snap installiert? Snap. Oh, ich habe
es. Okay, Snap install. Okay, aber ich erzähle jetzt erst mal kurz noch die Sache von der Arbeit,
fertig? Und jetzt installiert man das? Mail.ru. Gekommnet am Start. Snap install. Auch noch
Sudo. Und wenn ich mal mal vor einen Snap shot, dass ich auf jeden Fall rückstandslos wieder weg
bekomme. Man weiß ja nie. So, also ich erzähle jetzt mal kurz die Sache fertig. Und zwar,
wir hatten heute wieder so eine Selbstfeier-Veranstaltung auf der Arbeit. Kannst du dir
bitte mal dieses Tool anschauen? Ja, kann ich machen. Also, mach ich gleich. Ich erzähle jetzt
mal kurz die Sache fertig. Also, wir hatten heute wieder so eine Selbstfeier-Veranstaltung,
wo man sich von Anfang bis Ende geil findet. Es war aber ein bisschen schlechtes Timing,
richtige Stonks-Veranstaltung. Es war ein bisschen schlechtes Timing, weil sie haben
erst vorher ein paar Leute rausgeschmissen. Und das ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen doof,
wenn man quasi Leute rausschmeißt, eine Woche später eine Selbstfeier-Veranstaltung macht,
wo man erzählt, wie sicher die Arbeitsplätze sind, wie geil alle sind. Also, nicht am gleichen Tag,
aber so ungefähr in einer Woche Versatz. Also, das war schon das meist diskutierteste Thema.
Witzigerweise konnte man vorher in so einem Fragetool, in so einem Online-Frage-Umfragetool
konnte man Fragen für diese Veranstaltung einreichen. Da haben sie irgendeinen Vorstandsmensch
interviewt, also interviewt in Anführungsstrichen, also sprich, der wusste ja genau, was kommt. Und
da konnte man Fragen stellen im Vorfeld. Und wenn man sich die Fragen durchgelesen hat,
die waren echt nicht nett. Da waren dann beispielsweise übelst angepisste Außendienst-Mitarbeiter dabei,
so nach dem Motto, warum sind im Innendienst alle so faul, obwohl der Außendienst alles gibt. Solche
Fragenstande, letztendlich drin. Zumindest habe ich da gestern mal alle Fragen mir angeguckt,
habe ich mir, ich habe teilweise echt den Kopf geschüttelt und heute morgen,
jetzt ohne Scheiß, heute morgen, bevor die Veranstaltung losgeht, gucke ich in dieses
Fragetool, alle Fragen weg, bis auf, keine Ahnung, 12 Stück, die man gut beantworten kann. Da hat
sich da voll gelohnt, dass man den Scheiß vorher einreicht. Nein, man muss ihnen sagen,
sie haben mich dann doch noch ein bisschen überrascht. Sie haben tatsächlich,
naja, die Veranstalter waren es, wer sonst. Sie haben tatsächlich Fragen von gestern,
die kritisch waren, teilweise mit reingenommen, so war es nicht. Aber das waren, keine Ahnung,
20 ziemlich fiese, auch kritische Fragen. Und davon hat man vielleicht 5 Stück reingenommen.
Also, sehr selektiv, was da alles war. Zumindest, ich wollte euch nochmal richtig
krasse Big Brain Stonks-Logik erzählen. Zumindest ging es dann halt auch kurz darum,
was das für ein Signal quasi setzt, wenn man sich selbst feiert und erzählt so nach dem Motto,
wir sehen jetzt irgendwie das, zehnt ihr einen Folgen, die besten und jetzt noch besser und
bla bla bla. Und halt im gleichen Zug Leute raushaut. Da war halt auch eine Frage drin,
wie passt das irgendwie zusammen. Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, ob ich den genauen Wortlaut
korrekt hinbekomme. Aber, ich meine, das ist ganz klar, die Leute sind freigestellt, denen wurde
gesagt, entweder unterschreibst du einen Aufhebungsvertrag oder kannst du uns verklaren oder was auch immer.
Also, im Prinzip sind die Leute weg. Da gibt es nichts dran zu rütteln letztendlich. Da wird nie
wieder einer von denen auftauchen. Im Endeffekt ging es dann halt um die Frage, was das für ein
Signal setzt und so. Und die Antwort war so geil. Ich versuchte die mal, die Musik nicht zu laut,
ich versuchte die mal sinngemäß so halbwegs dem original Wortlaut entsprechend so halbwegs
hinzubekommen. Zumindest hat er erstmal gemeint, die Leute werden ja nicht entlassen,
sondern die stehen im Gespräch mit der Personalabteilung. Ich hab mir auch schon gedacht,
hä? Was zum Teufel? Also, die wurden nicht entlassen. Also, sie haben nicht einen entlassen.
Die stehen alle jetzt im direkten Gespräch mit der Personalabteilung und die Arbeitskraft der
Mitarbeiter wird wahrscheinlich woanders verortet werden. Das ist die geilste Stonkserklärung für
rausgeschmissen aller Zeiten, oder? Die Arbeitskraft der Mitarbeiter wird woanders verortet werden.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, voll lieb ich veräppeln oder was? Ihr habt die Leute rausgeschmissen,
dann sagt's wenigstens. Das ist mal eine Rede, das ist mal so eine geile, ultrageile Bezeichnung.
Das sagt sie demnächst auch. Müsst ihr demnächst auch sagen, wenn einer zu euch kommt und fragt,
ja, könnt ihr das und das machen? Und dann kannst du sagen, kann diese Arbeit nicht woanders
verortet werden? Das ist jetzt so unglaublich bescheuert. Stonks, Alter. Ja, also, muss man ja
sagen, so rhetorische Sachen haben sie ja drauf. Okay, ich ins Chat, weil ihr seid,
installiere ich mir jetzt mal echt ICQ. ICQ? Ich glaub's nicht, ich installiere ICQ. Fips,
das kann ich nicht. Wenn ich das jetzt nochmal erzähle, ist das nicht mal so lustig. Ja,
und dann haben sie sich ja ein bisschen gefeiert und so. Das waren wir aber allgemein gerne. Aber
das war schon geil, diese. Ja, der Chat wollte, dass ich ICQ installiere. Also hier, ICQM from
mail.ru. Exzellent. Okay, das Kommando nennt sich ICQ im Punkt ICQ. Alles, oh, oh, es geht
auch noch gut los. Gut, dass ich in der VM bin, gut, dass ich den Snapshot gemacht hab. Ach,
das da. Oh, da ist Elektronanwendung. Das ist eine Elektronanwendung, das schreit. Leute,
das schreit sowas von Elektronanwendung. Wenige Anwendungen schreien so Elektron wie das hier.
Gucken wir mal. Äh, was, was mach ich denn da? ICQ. Wenn ich richtig schreiben könnte,
ICQ. Okay, vielleicht ist doch keiner. Oh, das ist keine Elektronanwendung, Leute. Oh,
das ist eine komprimierte Elektronanwendung. Aber Leute, findet ihr nicht auch, das ist,
das schreit übelst nach Elektron, das ganze Ding, wenn ich das sehe. Wie ist denn das? Was
ist denn das, wenn das nicht Elektron ist? Qt mit Browser, Fenster oder so? Ach, Moment,
es ist ein Link auf Snap. Das ist ja im Container, da kann ich mir jetzt gar nicht angucken, was
das ist. Okay, Moment, ich lad mir mal die Debian-Variante runter. Äh, die Ubuntu-Variante,
dann entzippen wir das und gucken uns mal an, was das ist. Nee, das ist, das ist Elektron.
Ich könnte wetten, dass das Elektron ist. Wir laden das jetzt mal runter und gucken uns das an.
ICQ, ich hätte es ja nicht für möglich gehalten. Ah, das ist kein TGZ, das ist ein TXZ. Was
entpack ich denn das? Linux Unpack TXZ, was ist denn ich, was nehmen die da schon wieder
für komische Pack-Algorithmen, die kein Mensch verwendet? Aha, da XXF, einfach ohne Z. Okay,
klar. So, da ist es, ICQ. Okay, das ist ein fettes, ein fettes Binary-File. What the fuck?
Was Adobe? Nein, das ist ein SV. Okay, hier ist, hier ist das ganze HTML-Geschiss drinne.
Das ist ein Browser, das ist eine Browser-Anwendung. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist. In irgendwas
Binary-Verpacktes ist es, aber ich hab keinen Schimmer, was es ist, ehrlich gesagt. Was,
Bitrate? Ist die Bitrate schlecht? Nee, Bitrate ist okay. Das waren wahrscheinlich, jaja,
das war, das, das könnten schon SVGs gewesen sein, so genau hab ich es nicht gesehen. So
viel Text für die Bitrate, ernsthaft? Scroll, Scroll, Scroll, Scroll, Scroll, Scroll, Scroll,
Scroll. Okay, zoomen wir mal nach was, HTML. Tja. Das ist Kamera, das ist das Zeug aus
dem Kameramodul. Na, was könnte man suchen, um rauszukriegen, was es ist? Das ist, das
ist FFmpeg, das ist FFmpeg für Videogeschiss, okay. Keine Ahnung, wenn wir das gescheit
rauskriegen. Das ist, das ist das Tray, das ist das Tray-Icon. Äh, ja. Okay, ich weiß
nicht, was es ist, aber das muss ein Browser sein. Ihh, ich brauch, okay. Damit ist die
Sache schon mal gelaufen. Oh, das ist eine gute Idee. Äh, ähm, nach Main? Da gibt's
bisschen viel wahrscheinlich. Ah, ja, ja, doch, doch, doch, doch. Okay, das sind auf
jeden Fall C++ Symbols. Allerdings, das sagt ja an sich noch nicht viel, weil, ähm, die
Node.js Runtime ist ja auch C++. Also, ich mein, das kann durchaus ein Qt oder eine Node
Web, wie heißt das andere, wie heißt diese Electron Konkurrenz, äh, NW, NW Kit oder
irgendwie so. Also, das, das, das wird, ich bin mir da ziemlich sicher, dass das letztendlich
ein Browser ist, der da drinnen läuft. Versuchen wir mal nach Diff oder so. Diff, Span oder
so was. Span Style. Diff. Noch Qt, Qt. Ah, da finden wir zu viel. Ah, okay, es ist eine
Qt Anwendung, höchstwahrscheinlich. Es ist eine Qt Anwendung mit Browser, haben wir was
mit Browser Engine da drinnen oder so. Qt Text Browser, Qt Browser. Na, Chat, da sehen wir
uns einig, dass das ein Browser ist. Das ist allerdings nicht die Browser Engine. WebRTC,
das sieht auch nach Chrome aus. Das sieht auch nach Chrome aus. Ja, es ist eine Qt Anwendung
wahrscheinlich mit Qt Web Engine oder so was unten drunter. Also, es ist auf jeden Fall
ein Browser, aber es ist nicht einfach nur Electron, aber es ist nicht wirklich besser
als Electron, es ist nur anders als Electron. Ja, gut, also man kann sich nicht mit einer
E-Mail registrieren, dann hat sich das ja schon mal erledigt. Moment, Sign in. Moment, wie
macht man über Register? Wie macht man Register? Okay, nochmal, nochmal neu starten. Fake Telefon,
das hab ich nicht. Accept and okay. Ja, nee, kann ich nicht machen. Hab ich nicht. Hab
ich nicht, kein Fake Telefon. Omega Lul. Oben links? Was? Write us. Oder meine im Startbildschirm
oben links? Nee. What? LDD, gute Idee. Was denn oben links? Ja, Moment. Aber ich will
noch Sign up. Wie kann ich mich überhaupt registrieren? Kann man sich da nicht registrieren?
Muss man das hier drüber machen? Nein, nein, nein. LDD hast du recht, ist eine gute Idee.
Wobei das irgendwie so ein Self-Content Snap ist, weiß ich nicht, wie weit das was bringt.
Moment, wir müssen zählen Downloads. So, also was haben wir hier? Das bringt jetzt
wirklich großartig was. Es ist bloß die Standardgeschichten. Das sind keine Qt Libraries gelingt,
aber das kann ja auch sein, dass sie das irgendwie da mitbringen oder irgendwas. Das
ist aber auf jeden Fall eine Qt Anwendung. LDD zeigt dir an, was das Ding für Libraries
gelingt, aber ich glaube nur dynamisch gelingte, deswegen zeigt es dir nicht an, wenn sie das
statisch gelingt haben. Weil ich den Kram so selten benutzt, da bin ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so sicher. So, aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein Browser. Das ist sowas von
sicher. Wie groß ist denn der Kram? Wow, das ist ein Browser. Also wenn es jetzt noch
nicht sicher war, dass es ein Browser ist, das ist eine Qt Anwendung, statisch gelingt
irgendwie. Das sind die Russen, die juckt es auch nicht, dass du um eine statische Qt Anwendung
zu machen eigentlich eine Lizenz brauchst. Das ist denen wahrscheinlich vollkommen wurscht.
Den Qt Commodits und da ist ein Browser drin, da ist ein Qt Framework, ein Browser drin,
sonst kommst du nicht auf 111 MB. Was war es? Minus A? Minus C? Ah, exzellent. Ich wollte
schon immer mal wieder, wir brauchen jetzt unbedingt mal den Hexdump. Nicht, dass es
jetzt irgendwie großartig Sinn machen wird, aber einfach mal der Hexdump. 111 MB Hexdump,
das dauert jetzt ein bisschen. Also ich würde sagen, wir machen den Stream wieder aus, wir
können nichts anderes machen in der Zwischenzeit. Richtig, der Hacker, mein Herr, richtig. Also
ich mache mal wieder zu, weil ich habe keine Fake-Telefonnummer. Kann man nicht ausprobieren,
weil einer von euch eine Fake-Telefonnummer hat, dann kann ich das ausprobieren, aber
so nicht. So, wie kriege ich den Kram jetzt wieder runter? Einfach Snap, Remove. Das ist
die Kacke daran, dass die immer andere Bezeichnung haben, die Ubuntu-Jungs. So, alles wieder
weg. Exzellent, sehr schön. Gut, haben wir das installiert. Also, da kommen wir mal zur
eigentlichen Sache, die ich jetzt machen will. Wie gesagt, es gibt gar keinen langen Stream
heute, weil ich habe ja, ihr wisst ja, Zeit bis 22 Uhr. Am Wochenende dafür wieder ein
bisschen mehr. Und ich muss mir einen extra, ich muss mir einen Cloud-Server installieren.
Tatsächlich, weil ernsthaft nicht einfach nur für den Stream, sondern so richtig, weil
ich ihn verwenden will. Weil, ich zeige euch das mal, das haben wir letztens schon im Stream
festgestellt, weil ich verwende ja aktuell für Presence Detection in meiner Heimautomatisierung.
Also mal kurz zur Erklärung, was damit gemeint ist. Also Presence Detection ist dafür zuständig,
wenn man zum Beispiel ein Heimautomatisierungssystem hat, oder auch wenn du Google Maps hast, zu
gucken, wo man ist. So, das hat verschiedene Vorteile, wenn die Heimautomatisierung Files
hat. Ich habe es jetzt schon gelöscht. Also, das hat verschiedene Vorteile, wenn die Heimautomatisierung
weiß, wo man ist. So, das wollte ich jetzt sagen. Genau. Also, wenn die Heimautomatisierung
weiß, wo man ist, hat natürlich seine Vorteile. Man kann zum Beispiel, wenn man auf dem Heimweg
ist, die Klimaanlage einschalten lassen, wenn es über eine gewisse Temperatur ist oder
irgendwelche sowas. Zumindest, ich will, dass meine Heimautomatisierung weiß, wo ich bin.
So, ich habe jetzt da verschiedene Varianten, wie man das machen kann. Wenn man beispielsweise
ganz viele Google Produkte verwendet, ist es kein Ding, dann kann man das über Google
machen, aber erstens verwende ich nicht so viele Google Sachen und ich bin auch nicht
unbedingt so scharf drauf, dass Google überall weiß, wo ich bin. Ich gehe jetzt nicht so
weit, dass ich sage, irgendwie, da sitzt die NSA und guckt mir zu und so. Ich meine, man
muss es ja nicht übertreiben, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was mit meinen Daten passiert
und ich bin mittlerweile der Meinung, ich rück einfach nur noch das raus, was nötig
ist und alles andere nicht und mein Standort muss Google nur wirklich nicht wissen. So,
das heißt, ich habe noch verschiedene andere Möglichkeiten, um Presence Detection zu machen
für meine Heimautomatisierung. Beispielsweise eine Sache, die für Familien relativ beliebt
ist, ist das hier. Habe ich noch nicht benutzt, aber ich kenne das aus dem Home Assistant
Forum, das verwenden ganz viele. Keine Ahnung, ob das vielleicht auch einer von euch verwendet.
Das ist wohl auch recht beliebt, was Presence Detection angeht, aber nachdem ich gar keinen
Cloud Service haben will, der permanent mitschneidet, wo ich bin, mache ich das zur Zeit hier drüber.
Also, es gibt eine iPhone und eine iOS App, die können die Standortinformationen zu einem
eigenen Server schicken. Unter der Haube machen die exakt das gleiche, was Google Maps
macht, was Live 360 macht. Also, letztendlich verwenden die ja alle die gleichen Betriebssystems
Schnittstellen, um Location Tracking zu machen. So, und das ist das Ding, äh, ich meine,
ich meine Android App und eine iOS App. So, und ich verwende das Ding hier. Kaut so aus.
Das ist alles Schwachsinn, braucht kein Mensch. Wichtig ist die Funktion, dass man Sachen
zu, dass man den aktuellen Standort zu einem eigenen Server schicken kann. So, und die
Sache ist jetzt die. Ich habe bisher diesen Anbieter hier verwendet, um meine Sachen hinzuschicken.
Ich weiß, es klingt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen widersprüchlich, weil ich habe ja gesagt,
ich will ja gar keine Cloud Sachen verwenden, um meine, meinen Standort zu tracken, aber
da ist es ein bisschen anders. Das ist kein Tracking-Anbieter, sondern das verwende ich
einfach nur, um die Daten weiterzuleiten und die sind eh verschlüsselt. Also sprich, ähm,
das da ist der ganze Payload verschlüsselt vom Standort und ich verwende das hier, um
die Sachen weiterzuleiten von meinem Handy an meine Heimautomatisierung. Die greift
die dann da ab, weil ich brauche irgendeinen Server im Internet, wo ich das von meinem
Handy aus hinschicken kann, weil ich hab keinen Bock, ehrlich gesagt, irgendwelche Ports weiterzuleiten
oder vielleicht VPN zu machen oder sowas, nur für Presence Detection. Zumal es mit
VPN auch das Problem gibt, dass wenn das Handy die Positionsdaten schicken will, dass
VPN gar nicht aufgebaut ist. Das, das funktioniert nicht. So, also was man machen könnte ist,
man könnte sich natürlich daheim einen MQTT-Server hinstellen, dann lasse aber die Frage, ok,
wie greife ich da drauf zu? Die beste Variante wäre, ich stelle direkt hinter das Unity-Media-Modem,
also quasi zwischen meinem Router und zwischen dem Modem, stelle ich, also, nein, zwischen
dem Unity-Media-Router, das ist ja nicht nur ein Modem, zwischen dem Unity-Media-Router
und meinem Mikrotik-Router, würde ich so DMZ-mäßig vielleicht noch einen Raspberry Pi hinstellen
mit einem MQTT-Server drauf und würde Port-Weiterleitung machen, aber in Anbetracht der Tatsachen,
dass, wer weiß, wie das in Unity-Media weiter läuft mit DS Lite, aktuell habe ich zwar
noch ein vollständiges Dual-Stack, aber man weiß ja nicht, wie das in Zukunft aussieht,
doch man kann auf dem iPhone einen VPN definieren, das funktioniert, das Problem ist, wenn das
iPhone bzw. diese App der Meinung ist, sie muss jetzt ein Location-Update schicken, dann
muss vorher das VPN aufgebaut werden, wenn nicht, schlägt das fehl und das ist nicht
gesüngt, also sprich, das erfordert sehr viel Glück, dass gerade das VPN aufgebaut
ist im Background, während die App updaten will, das züngt sich nicht, also sprich,
die meisten Location-Updates gehen ins Leere, weil das VPN nicht aufgebaut ist, im Hintergrund,
das iPhone baut ja alles ab, die sind ja bei Apple da sehr ressourcenschonend, was das
angeht, es gibt ja beim iPhone keine Hintergrundanwendung in dem Sinn, also beim iPhone ist es so,
dass Hintergrundanwendungen maximal 10 Minuten laufen dürfen und dann auch nur ganz, ganz
minimal CPU-Zeit verwenden und dann werden sie nur alle paar Minuten mal wieder aufgeweckt
und dürfen dann irgendwie auch nur 5 Sekunden was machen oder sowas, also das ist, und der
iOS ist wirklich ziemlich restriktiv, was du im Hintergrund machen darfst, deswegen gibt
es so Sachen wie Geofencing oder diese iOS-Location-Updates, da handelt das Betriebssystem das, und das
weckt dann quasi die App auf, die sich dafür registriert haben bei iOS, so nach dem Motto
ey, iOS, sag mir mal Bescheid, wenn es einen Major Location Change gegeben hat und Major
Location Change ist bei iOS, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht aus dem Kopf, ich glaube 500 Meter
innerhalb von 5 Minuten, ich weiß nicht, was ein Major Location Change bei iOS ist und
wenn man, dann wird die App aufgeweckt und dann schickt die das, so ungefähr, also ich
bin aber auch kein iOS-App-Entwickler, ich hab sowas noch nicht im Detail gemacht, ich
weiß nur so ungefähr, wie das funktioniert, Captain Sieker sagt, das stimmt nicht ganz,
kommt drauf an, mit Aufwandland komme ich auf ca. 15K Datenpunkte pro Tag, also quasi
immer, gut, es frisst dann aber auch dementsprechend Batterie, das kann man da auch machen, man
kann auch einstellen, man möchte permanent das benutzen, aber dann muss man vorher extra
noch anhaken, ja ich bin damit einverstanden, dass es mehr Batterie verwendet, also das Standard
Tracking unter iOS ist glaube ich Major Location Change oder wie das heißt, das sind glaube
ich 500 Meter oder 250 Meter innerhalb von einer gewissen Zeitspanne, ja genau, so und
das verwende ich und irgendwie müssen die Daten zu meiner Heimautomatisierung kommen
und das mache ich aktuell da drüber, ich habe einfach einen internen MQTT Broker geprütscht
damit, die Sache ist jetzt nur die, die haben ihr Free Tier eingestellt und ich sehe es
nicht ein, 5 Euro im Monat zu bezahlen für einen poplichen Low End MQTT Service, den
ich verwenden kann, wenn ich doch für, pass mal auf, wenn ich doch für 2,89 Euro im Monat
ein komplettes System bekomme, warum soll ich das machen, das ist doch total hirnrissig,
also ich habe die Auswahl 5 Euro zu bezahlen für einen Poplicht MQTT Server ohne alles
oder für ein komplettes LILUX System, natürlich nehme ich dann ein komplettes LILUX System,
wenn ich es eh schon bezahlen muss, es kostet nur die Hälfte für einen kompletten LILUX
Server, also warum soll ich das, warum soll ich das nicht machen, so, ich muss auch ein
bisschen Chat gucken, ich habe wieder die Hälfte übersehen, modernes Android ist echt schlimm
für Background Apps, ja, das ASUS Tablet was ich mal kurzzeitig hatte oder was ich immer
noch habe, aber kurzzeitig benutzt habe, weil es absolute Shit ist, das kann ich gar
nicht, das war wirklich ZenPad oder sowas, ZenPad 10 oder so, das ist wirklich absoluter
Müll, weiß nicht ob es das ist, aber absoluter Crap, ich habe das gekauft als es neu war,
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es das war, hatte irgendwie 3,50 Euro gekostet, da hätte ich
mir lieber ein iPad damals holen sollen, aber ich habe mir gedacht, ok, Android ist meine
Mutter mehr gewöhnt und so, das war eigentlich für mich das Tablet und ich habe das gekauft
und es war von Anfang an kacke, erstens hatten die den ROM installiert, der Background Apps
killt, was für meine Heimautomatisierung wieder absolut von Arsch ist und dazu kam,
dass die nie Android Updates geliefert haben, nie, die haben, ich habe das Tablet gekauft
und die haben es eingestellt, was oder 1 Euro VPS bei IONOS, was zum Geier ist IONOS, habe
ich nur nie gehört, IONOS, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, IONOS, klingt ja schon exzellent,
ok, wo, wo ist er, Hosting, ihh, ist das 1 und 1, ist das Marcel Davis, so also, wo gibt
es denn hier überhaupt was, dedicated Hosting, VPS Hosting, zu den Tarifen, günstige Server
ab einem Euro im Monat, ah, Gebaided, Gebaided, das ist gar nicht 1 Euro im Monat, es ist
eh nur Angebot 1 Euro im Monat, also das funktioniert so nicht, Winni Baby Moin, unter VPSS, ach
hier, ach ja, das ist gar nicht so schlecht, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, ich meine,
guck mal, das ist ja ultra billig, also man, das ist jetzt, also das ist die Hälfte ungefähr
von dem was bei Hetzner kostet und bei Hetzner kriegst du halt 2G RAM, 20G SSD und Traffic
und hier kriegste halt nur 500, ok, das ist, aber es reicht, aha, machen wir da jetzt einen
Account, das probieren wir jetzt aus, ich hab das noch nie ausprobiert hier, ok, also
204 PS, doppelte, doppelte ist 1G RAM, ach komm, scheiß drauf, wir machen, wir machen
wirklich absolut Low End Shit, so, 2104 ist ok, kein Cloud Backup, obwohl ich mich da
mit irgendeiner E-Mail Adresse registrieren muss, die es gibt, was ist denn das jetzt am
besten, hm, welchen Zentrum Deutschland, ok, weiter, Domain hinzufügen, nee, brauchen
wir nicht, ach so, nee Leute, ich kann das gar nicht machen jetzt, ich kann das gar nicht
mit jetzt eins und eins machen, weil da müsste ich bei Cloudflare mich einloggen und mein
DNS umstellen und ich kann mein DNS bei Cloudflare nicht umstellen, weil ich meine Zugangsdaten
hier nicht auf dem Streamingrechner hab, da machen wir das jetzt doch mal mit Hets, vielleicht
probieren wir das das nächste Mal aus, so, also weiter, was wollen die, ok, jetzt wollen
sie, dass man Ionos Kunde wird, Ionos Kunde, wieso musst du da was umstellen, weil ich,
also geht darum, weil ich mein DNS über Cloudflare mache, so Cloudflare bietet das kostenlos
an, dass man, kannst du erstmal mit der IP arbeiten, nee, ich will ja ein Zertifikate
ausstellen und so, dann geht das schlecht, also Cloudflare kennen die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich
von irgendeiner DDoS-Protection, Spam-Protection und Gedöns- und Captcha-Geschiss, was man
manchmal lösen muss, aber Cloudflare bietet kostenlose DNS-Server an, die man über eine
API ansteuern kann, das ist natürlich praktisch, weil mein Domain-Registrar, wo ich meine
Domain registriert hab, übrigens, ich empfehle da kein hinzugehen, aber das ist halt übelst
billig gewesen, die haben zwar auch eine DNS logischerweise, weil ohne DNS kannst du ja
deine Domains auflösen, das sagt ja der Name schon direkt vorher, aber die haben keine
API für den DNS und wenn man sich Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate ausstellen lassen will für Server, die man
intern verwendet, dann muss man das mit DNS-Challenge machen, sich die Zertifikate ausstellen lassen
und dann braucht man ein DNS, wo man über die API drauf zugreifen kann, weil ansonsten
musst du alle drei Monate dich von Hand in das Webinterface einloggen und ein DNS-Challenge
von Hand machen, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, deswegen ist mein DNS bei Cloudflare und ich
hab mir schon zwei Domains, oh Mist, ich hab was vergessen Leute, ich hab meine Cloudflare-Zugangsdaten
hier jetzt nicht, das ist kacke, ich kann das gar nicht machen, da muss ich jetzt mal
gespannt sein, hab ich die in meinem Passport-Change gesyncht stehen? Cloudflare, exzellent, ich
hab sie, Passport-Safe-FTW, ja, ne, ich hab die Domains umgestellt bei Cloudflare, aber
ich hab sie logischerweise noch nicht auf den neuen Server, den ich mir anlege, umgestellt,
weil den, den weiß ich die IP noch gar nicht, guck mal, ich hab doch den Server noch gar
nicht angelegt, woher soll ich wissen, was dieser Server für eine IP kriegt? Passport-Safe,
ja, Keypass, das heißt, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der für eine IP kriegt, deswegen muss
ich mich bei Cloudflare gleich einloggen und die, den DNS umstellen, das machen wir gleich,
das machen wir gleich, erstmal legen wir den Server an, und ich mach das jetzt nicht bei,
obwohl ich meine Dinger hab, weil da müsste ich mich jetzt erstmal mit Paypal einloggen
im Stream, will ich nicht, und da müsste ich mir einen Account machen, das probieren wir
vielleicht mal, das probieren wir vielleicht mal das nächste Mal aus, oder ich probiere
mal, ob ich das, warte mal, wir probieren das mal aus, ich mach das jetzt mal schnell,
mach das mal, ich mach das mal, aber im Incognito-Tab, da ich dann gleich wieder, gleich wieder
zumachen kann, also was wollen wir haben, nein, nein, nicht ihr Einstieg in den Onlinehandel,
wir wollen haben, nee, mach ich nicht, mach ich nicht, ich mach jetzt Hetzen, das dauert
sonst zu lang, das dauert sonst zu lang, und ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wie dieses Webinterface
aussieht von eins und eins, das heißt, ich hab keinen Bock, dass dann irgendwie meine
E-Mail noch liege und so, nicht, dass das großartig schlimm wäre, aber ich hab auch
keine Ahnung, ob das nicht irgendwelche privaten Sachen dann anzeigt, wir machen das ja erstmal
mit dem Hetzer-System, vielleicht probieren wir eins und eins dann dann mal aus, das nächste
Mal, so, ich leg mal, ich leg mal ne neue Kiste an, also wir wollen keinen Server in Helsinki
haben, wir wollen was in, in Falkenstein, wo, was, wo ist denn Falkenstein, macht keinen
Unterschied für so ne kleine Kiste, Falkenstein, der Luftkurort im vorder, vorderen bayerischen,
im vorderen bayerischen, hier, weiß man nicht, im vorderen bayerischen Wald, aha, das ist
so ein typisches Ding am Arsch der Welt, wo ich mir vorstellen kann, dass es da durchaus
noch mehr Rechenzentren gibt, da ist es, Museum, Jagd und Wild, guck mal, da ist Nürnberg
und das ist nicht weit voneinander entfernt, also sprich, äh Moment, wo ist Frankfurt,
ja, also von da nach da müssen wir jetzt, innerhalb von Deutschland ist das ganze egal,
so, also, also, wenn wir mal nach Falkenstein gehen wir mal, dann nehmen wir ein Ubuntu
20.04, man hat bei Hetzer eine ganz gute Auswahl, also man kann in dem, man kann mehr
Images installieren als nur die hier, die haben, die haben, äh, wenn man das System
ausschaltet, haben die, glaube ich, 20 verschiedene Sachen zur Auswahl, so, Ubuntu 20.04 ist okay,
Fedora ist absolut nicht mein Fall, Debian kann man verwenden, CentOS ist auch nicht
mein Fall, das liegt hauptsächlich daran, CentOS auf der Arbeit verwenden und CentOS
geht mir auf den Keks, vielleicht, deswegen mache ich alles, was ich nicht für die Arbeit
mache, mache ich mit Ubuntu Server, hast du deinen Hetzer Account mit Paypal verifiziert,
ja, ich glaube schon, ja, ja, ich glaube schon, ich muss ja schon ein paar Sachen bezahlen,
so, übrigens, ich wollte noch ein paar Sachen fertig beantworten im Chat grad, ähm, nein,
natürlich nicht Chat, der Chat würde, würde niemals irgendwas mit geleakten Informationen
anstellen, äh, warum Ubuntu und nicht Debian, das hat keinen, keinen großartigen Grund,
ich verwende beides ganz gern, aber irgendwie gefällt mir das Gesamtpaket bei Ubuntu besser,
auch wenn es keinen großen Unterschied ist, es ist jetzt reine, reine Geschmackssache,
hat jetzt keinen größeren, keinen größeren Grund, es gibt eine Sache, die mir persönlich
bei Ubuntu extrem auf den Sack geht, das habe ich schon oft gesagt, und das ist Netplan,
haben sie sich überlegt bei Ubuntu, dass man jetzt, ähm, seine Netzwerk-Config mit
per Jammel schreiben soll, das ist absolut hirnrissig, also wer sich den Kack ausgedacht
hat, den, den, den müsste man wirklich, äh, den ganzen Tag Jammel schreiben lassen, dass
er mal sieht, was, was, was, ok, wahrscheinlich findet das derjenige noch geil, wenn er, ähm,
was den ganzen Tag machen muss, den sollte man als Strafe mal, äh, für einen Tag in
das Facebook, äh, oder YouTube, YouTube Content Moderationsteam stecken, ich glaube, das will
eh keiner länger als Tag machen, ja, aber, also Netzwerk-Config, Netzwerk-Config, ähm,
in Jammel ist irgendwie, ja, also, ich verstehe den Sinn nicht davon, warum man eine Netzwerk-Config
in Jammel braucht, so schlimm waren jetzt die Config-Files vorher auch nicht, und, ähm,
letztendlich ist Netplan nochmal ein Aufsatz auf einem Aufsatz, ich meine, man sieht es
da hier, die verwenden Network-D, das ist schonmal ein Aufsatz auf Netzwerk-Gedöns, ähm,
also wenn ihr mich fragt, ich fand die Old-School-Debial-Interfaces eigentlich mit am elegantesten, so,
und wenn man schon Network-D verwendet, dann kann man Network-D auch direkt verwenden und
muss das nicht umständlich nochmal über einen Netplan-Wrapper oder so machen, das ergibt
für mich eigentlich keinen Sinn, und, äh, Network-D ist an sich ganz cool, da kann man
beispielsweise seine Interfaces umbenennen lassen, je nachdem, was für Netzwerk-Karte
Hersteller ist und so was, also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, hey, äh, das ist ein Interface
mit 10G und dieser Hersteller, und dann heißt das dann, dann heißt das Interface nicht
mehr, äh, ENP028, sondern das Interface heißt dann 10G-Intel oder so, also Netplan ist,
äh, nicht Netplan, eh, Network-D hat seine Vorteile, aber Netplan braucht wirklich kein
Match. Ja, Selmo sehe ich auch so, also entweder die stinknormalen, also die stinknormalen
Network-Upscripts von Debian waren mir persönlich immer noch am liebsten. Ja, sehe ich auch
so. So, ähm, kurz hier durchscrollen. Keine Ahnung. Genau, Keypads verwende ich. Naja,
die zwei Euro habe ich schon noch. Ähm, Chat, ich kann die Seite, ich kann die Seite jetzt
nicht aufmachen. Was hältst du vom Network-Manager? Ja, ist ganz, ist ganz praktisch, ist ganz
praktisch, wenn man, äh, VPNs und so hat und das nicht alles von Hand einrichten will.
Network-Manager ist okay. Also, auf dem Server würde ich es nicht verwenden unbedingt, aber
ich finde es nicht schlecht, ich finde es echt, kann man, kann man nehmen. Das beste
am Network-Manager ist übrigens auch, äh, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich hier einen Zettel
habe, dass man den Kram ganz gut hier über Terminal GUI machen kann, anstatt dass man
rein Konfig-Dateien editieren muss. Ne, ich habe keine Browser-Integration. Äh, für,
für Keypads. So, äh, was wollte ich denn, wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen. Genau, Chat,
ich muss euch, ich muss euch noch was erzählen. Und zwar, was wir heute auf der Arbeit gefunden
haben im E-Mail-Filter, auch geil. Ähm, ab und zu, ab und zu kriegen wir mal so Reports,
so welche E-Mails auf dem Spam hängen bleiben und so. Und, äh, dass irgendwas, dass irgendwas
nicht geht und im, im, im. Ja, und dann, dann muss man dann manchmal gucken, so, ok, warum
sind da so viele E-Mails von irgendwie einem Domain-Provider. Und da war, da waren heute
irgendwie, fragt mich nicht, 4000 Mails drinne von einem E-Mail-Provider Kockly. Ich kann
die Seite jetzt nicht aufmachen. Ich habe die Seite heute, ich habe die Seite heute
Mittag mal auf gehabt, um, um, äh, weil Spaß ist halber zu gucken, was das ist. Das ist
irgendein Provider, wo man, wo man per Bit, wo man irgendwie mit Bitcoins, wo man irgendwie
mit Bitcoins E-Mails mieten kann oder sowas. Ich habe nur gesehen, ich habe nur gesehen,
E-Mail-Postflächer und Bitcoins. Da habe ich mir gedacht, ok, das spricht schon für
äußerst seriöse Sachen. Und, ja, dann bin ich wieder runter. Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich fand es so lustig. Ok, der, äh, der Atrix, äh, was, Atrixen, der kennt das. Nee, also,
mir war das jetzt neu. Also, das ist keine, keine Gatschi-Buzz-Seite und, ne, keine Porn-Seite
irgendwie. Das ist so ganz normale. Ich weiß nicht, wie seriös das Ganze ist. Ich fand
es so witzig, dass da bei uns so viele Logs heute drinstehen. Kockly. Äh, Sascha Hemy
kann ich mir vorstellen. Also, generell, wenn man mit unentkunden und gar entkunden Hardware
zu tun hat, da findet man bestimmt viele Sachen, die man gar nicht sehen will. Was hältst du
von PHP-Zukunftsplänen? Was sind da die PHP-Zukunftspläne? Irgendjemand hat vorhin gefragt noch, ob das
mit der Steckdose-Firmware funktioniert hat. Ja, hat's. Stimmt, Ubuntu 10 kommt raus, ja.
Ja, hier, genau. Äh, haben die letztes, äh, haben die Steckdosen das letztes Mal geklappt
mit der Custom-Firmware. Soweit ich weiß, sind die noch immer aus und wieder eingegangen.
Also, hat funktioniert. Wer dabei war, es gab ja das Problem mit den, mit den selbst
gefleschten Steckdosen-Leisten, dass eine der Steckdosen-Leisten, nur eine, immer an
und aus gegangen ist. Und ich hab die dann mal abgemacht und hab die über Nacht liegen
lassen, weil ich den Stream ausgemacht hab. Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben, aber am anderen
Tag ging die Tate los. Hab keine Ahnung warum. Kein Schimmer. So, also, machen wir mal weiter.
Müssen wir langsam, müssen wir langsam das, das geduldes mal anlegen, sonst, wenn da,
ich mal die Basics-Sachen fertig. Also, äh, SSD, kleinste Dings, 289 im Monat. Ups, Volume
brauchen wir keinen. SSH-Key. Die Fold-SSH-Key. Kann ich euch übrigens empfehlen, macht das
nach Möglichkeit. Äh, wenn das, wenn das euer, euer Anbieter erlaubt, die meisten macht
das, machen, machen das, wenn man den SSH-Key hinterlegen kann. Macht das, weil ansonsten
kriegt man per Mail oder, oder irgendwie per einmaligem Token, wie auch immer, nen Hut-Zugang,
muss ich einloggen, muss das selbst machen. Lass den SSH-Key defaultmäßig machen und
gut ist. Dann könnt ihr euch gleich einloggen, ohne Passport. Musstest du auch 20 Euro beim
verifizieren? Was? Nö. Nein. Ich musste den doch nicht zum, nein, ich musste nicht zum
verifizieren bezahlen. Ich hab nen Server dort, also der Account, den gibt's schon ein
bisschen länger. Ähm, ich hab den, ich hab nen Server da, ich hab da ne Kiste gehabt
und hab dann am Ende des Monats bezahlt, ganz normal über Paypal und gut ist. Pay, schon
mitbekommen, dass man Paypal jetzt mit Bitcoins benutzen kann? Nein. So, ähm, äh, ja der
ESX auf dem Raspberry Pi hat ganz gut funktioniert, aber nicht, dass man damit was Sinnvolles
machen kann. Was PHP will ein Compiler einfügen? Bald gibt's, bald gibt's native, native Microcontroller
PHP. Da wart ich schon drauf. ESP32PHP. Der SSH-Key ist für den Root-User, ja. Ja, richtig.
Ahja, und wenn ihr SSH-Keys hinzufügt, ich sag das jetzt nicht, Chat, weil ich denke,
dass der Chat alles voller Noobs ist. Das muss ich nicht denken, das, das weiß ich
ja eh schon. Nein, ich sag das nicht, weil der Chat voller Noobs ist, aber ich sag das,
weil sogar Leute, die dafür bezahlt werden auf, bei mir auf der Arbeit, mir schon ihre
Private Keys geschickt haben als ihre Public Keys. Also wenn man SSH-Keys irgendwo hinzufügt,
dann nimmt man den Public Key und nicht den Private Key. Also sonst kannst du den Key
wegschmeißen und gleich nochmal neu generieren. So, also, create and buy, excellent. So, zweite
Kiste, exquisite IP. Eins, acht, drei. Die haben aber ganz schön viele IP-Ranges hier
bei Hetzner. Das letzte Mal, letzte Kiste, die hab ich, die hab ich weggeschmissen, schon
wieder, die hatten wieder ne ganz andere IP-Range. Die haben schon ordentlich was. So, okay, SSH,
bam, yes. Ach, Moment, nicht Max, root, root. So, erstmal ein Update machen, also immer,
das ist das allererste Mal, wenn ich auf irgendeine Ubuntu-Kiste komme. Erstmal ein Update,
Upgrade. Was läuft eigentlich bei der Hetzner Cloud runter als Virtualisierung? Ich vermute
mal KVM für die Linux-Kisten. Weiß nicht, ob wir das rausbekommen. Man bekommt es vielleicht
an der Mac, an der Mac bekommt man es vielleicht raus. Get what? Nee, wie war das? Ist ESX
nicht normal? Doch, im Enterprise-Umfeld ist ESX normal, aber Linux lässt sich echt gut
mit KVM, ach, das ist eine KVM. Aber Linux lässt sich echt gut mit KVM virtualisieren.
Also KVM ist es. So, gucken wir uns mal an, ob der auch der Meinung ist, dass das QEMU
ist. Die Range gibt es gar nicht. QEMU. Aber ok, wenn das mein, dass es KVM ist, das passt
auch. Also es ist KVM, das kann ich auch nachvollziehen. Also Windows über KVM würde ich nicht machen,
Windows würde ich wahrscheinlich immer über ESX machen. Oder im Zweifelsfall auch über
Hyper-V oder so. Aber Linux lässt sich ziemlich gut über KVM virtualisieren. Ist die Konsole
nun sicher zu erreichen? Die hatten vorher kein TLS 1.2. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
Ahnung. Mal ausprobieren. Konsole, wo ist denn die überhaupt? Hier oben war die irgendwo.
Moment, da. Excellent. Chat, was passiert jetzt eigentlich, wenn man auf diese Konsole
drauf geht? Könnt ihr dann auch einfach drauf zugreifen? Ah, nee, geht nicht. Da hätten
wir gleich hier Security-Dings melden können. Die ist jetzt, ist die, sieht man das, das
ist was, was die für eine TLS-Version verwenden. Keine Ahnung. Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich
im Netzwerk-Tab gucken, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das jetzt raus bekomme, ehrlich
gesagt. Gut, jetzt wollen wir erstmal ein Upgrade, aktuelle Pakete installieren, zack,
gibt kernel-Update, wunderbar, können wir gleich rebooten danach. Reboot tut gut. So,
und das erste, was man macht, das erste, was man macht, wenn man irgendeine Kiste in
der Cloud hat, also zumindest das erste, was ich mache, wenn ich dieses System ernsthaft
verwenden will, jetzt nicht einfach nur ein bisschen im Stream rumzuspielen. Warum machst
du nicht Updates und Upgrades, weil ich dann mehr tippen muss? Hat keinen, hat keinen
tieferen Sinn. So, das erste, was ich bei jeder Ubuntu-Kiste mache, die ich nicht einfach
noch für ein Stream zum rumbasteln, nee, Platte-Verschlüssel mache ich nicht. Platte-Verschlüssel
mache ich nicht. Hier kommt nichts wirklich Privates drauf, was ich verschlüsseln muss.
Das erste, was ich mache, ist ufw allow ssh. Das ufw ist die Ubuntu-Firewall, das ist quasi
so, nee, fail-to-ban mache ich auch nicht. Das erste, was ich mache, ist mal die Firewall
an. Also ich erlaube erstmal ssh. Was, wie, wird was gehen? Okay, ich weiß nicht, was
du meinst, Matt. Also, fail-to-ban für dich, aber ich glaube, das brauchen wir nicht.
Grosse Nectar sind eh schon wieder am Start. Wie würde das gegen Cloud Server verschlüsseln?
Das haben wir schon mal in einem Stream gemacht. Wenn du wirklich komplett deinen Server in
der Cloud verschlüsseln willst, also so wirklich Vollverschlüsselung, dann musst du das Betriebssystem
selbst installieren, sodass du einen Installer kriegst und dass du im Installer oder zumindest
während des Installers schon deine Disk-Verschlüsselung machen kannst, dass du halt dann rebooten
kannst und musst dir mal Passport eingeben und so. Das haben wir mal in einem Stream
gemacht, funktioniert relativ gut. Bei Hetzner war es ziemlich krampf, kann ich mich noch
daran erinnern, dass man den Ubuntu Installer gebootet bekommen hat, weil man konnte bei
Hetzner kein Netboot verwenden, also kein Netboot XYZ PXE, weil die irgendein so ganz
komische, müssen wir mal gucken, ob das immer noch so ist, die hatten so eine ganz merkwürdige
Netzwerk-Config das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, sodass es quasi die Default-Route nicht
im Netz war oder sowas. So ganz komisches Zeug. Ja genau, guck mal. Das ist das Interface,
das ist meine Public Interface IP und das hier ist die Default-Route. Das ist eigentlich
eine Kombination, die geht gar nicht. Also normalerweise muss die Default-Route immer
im Netz sein, wo das Interface ist. In dem Fall geht das, weil die irgendeine Special-Netzwerk-Option
gesetzt haben. Das letzte Mal im Stream haben wir das versucht rauszukriegen. Irgendeine
Special DHCP-Option haben die gesetzt, sodass das geht. Ich frag mich nicht mehr, ich krieg's
aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen und deswegen kannst du keinen PXE-Boot machen, weil PXE
Special-Netzwerk-Option nicht unterstützt. So, deswegen war es bei Hetzener ziemlicher
Krampf, da komplette Vollverschlüsselung zu machen, aber braucht man meistens auch nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, in dem Fall ist es sogar besser. Man würde die Verzeichnisse irgendwie,
die nennt sich das, also nicht per Lux-Verschlüssel, also nicht per Block-Device verschlüsseln,
sondern man würde sowas wie ENC-FS oder so was hier oder E-Crypt-FS oder irgendwie sowas
verwenden. Das verschlüsselt Dateien, also das verschlüsselt quasi nicht Festplatten,
sondern es verschlüsselt auf Dateibasis. Die zwei Sachen wären dann wahrscheinlich
sinnvoller, wenn man wirklich da sensible Sachen drauf ablegen will, wo man nicht weiß, was
damit ist. Aber ich habe da auf Cloud-System eh keine großartigen sensible Sachen drauf
liegen und ich kann auch gerne empfehlen, großartig sensible Sachen drauf zu legen.
Wie sich der Chat jetzt an Default-Route erfreut. Hier ist die Default-Route-Chat. Was ist euch
lieber? Default-Route? Oder was? Default-Route? Oder Default-Rute? Default-Route? Ich sag mal,
ich bleib bei Default-Route jetzt. Wie heißt ein Route auf Deutsch bei Microsoft? Die haben
doch immer so tolle Übersetzungen. Wie? Routing-Tabelle? Das kann ja nicht sein. Die haben ein normales
Wort dafür. Was mach? Ein Alias? Für was? Alias für was? Chat, ihr lenkt mich wieder
ab. Das wird im Leben nicht fertig, wenn ich so weitermache. Also das erste, was ich immer
mache ist, ich schalte die Firewall ein. Und damit das funktioniert, muss man vorher sagen,
man will SSH erlauben. Ich hoffe, ich hab das schon gemacht. Und jetzt muss man erstmal
SSH erlauben und dann sagt man UFW-Default-Deny. Und wenn ich das jetzt nicht vergessen hab,
dann sperre ich mich aus. So, passt. Und jetzt UFW-Enable. Yes, gut. So, jetzt ist die Firewall
an und es ist nur Port 22 erlaubt. Wenn man nicht zuerst SSH erlaubt, kriegt man sich
selbst raus. So, nachdem wir Kernel-Update gemacht haben, rebooten wir jetzt mal. Ich
kann auch ein paar Sachen installieren, die ich eigentlich immer installiere. Das nehme
ich ab, erst mal ein T-Max drauf, einen vollen Vimt drauf und das da drauf. Das ist aber
persönlicher Geschmack. Damit fragt der einen, ob man wirklich rebooten will. Weil ich hab
schon ab und zu mal Kisten-Reboote, die ich nicht rebooten will, weil ich halt als root
eingeloggt war und halt Reboot gemacht hab, obwohl ich dachte, ich bin auf einer anderen
Ubuntu-Kiste. So, wenn man das installiert hat und man macht Reboot, dann fragt der einen
sagt, ey, Moment mal. Willst du wirklich rebooten? Und dann musst du den Namen vom Host eingeben,
dass du rebooten willst und dann passt das. Das hab ich mir angewöhnt, das zu installieren,
zumindest bei Ubuntu-Kisten, nachdem ich manchmal aus Versehen Dinger rebooted hab, die ich
nicht rebooten will. Das ist praktisch. Das ist auch uralt, das ist ein Programm von 1995
oder so. Das ist antik schon, das hat schon wirklich Spinnweben. So, jetzt gucken wir
mal, ob wir wieder da sind. Das wird mal ein Bankletzten stauen, ja. So, jetzt kommen wir
zu der eigentlichen Sache. Jetzt hab ich die Firebolt eingeschaltet. Das ist immer das
erste, was ich mache. Wozu T-Max? Naja, falls du mal im Hintergrund was laufen lassen willst
oder so. Der Vorteil von T-Max ist halt, wenn jetzt hier, keine Ahnung, ich mach jetzt mal,
ich starte mal stellvertretend was, was ein bisschen läuft. So, und wenn ich jetzt meine
SSH-Verbindung ausmache, dann läuft die T-Max-Session weiter. So, ich sag euch jetzt mal, ich kill
jetzt mal, ich kill jetzt mal meine SSH-Session. Normalerweise wäre jetzt der Befehl abgekackt,
aber nachdem ich jetzt eine T-Max-Session laufen hab, läuft er noch. Generell, wenn
man Sachen macht, die ein bisschen länger dauern oder wenn man einfach an der Stelle
weiter machen will, wo man aufgehört hat, ist so ein T-Max immer äußerst praktisch.
Man kann es auch mit Screen machen, ja. Man kann es natürlich auch mit Screen machen.
Wobei T-Max einen Vorteil hat finde ich, ich weiß, das geht mit Screen auch, dass dieses
ganze Panel-Management und sowas, das hat ja Screen glaube ich nicht. Und, also sprich,
du hast keine Sessions, du hast keine Splits und sowas mit Screen. Und ich finde auch,
dass das Sharing von Sessions in T-Max deutlich einfacher ist. Also, wenn du eine Session
sharen willst mit T-Max, das machen wir auf der Arbeit zum Beispiel öfters, wenn irgendwie
was ist, sagen wir mal keine Ahnung, auf irgendeiner Proxy-Kiste oder so ist was im Arsch und es
guckt einer und findet es nicht und fragt mich dann, ob ich mal mitgucken kann oder umgedreht
ich finde etwas nicht und fragt einen, ob ich mal mitgucken kann, dann geht man einfach
auf die Kiste, macht eine T-Max-Session auf, sagt dem anderen, hier Session ist auf, dann
macht der andere, macht dann das hier, T-Max Attach und dann siehst du dann, dann kannst
du zusammen in der gleichen T-Max-Session rumwursten. Das geht mit Screen auch, aber
das finde ich viel umständlicher. Mit Screen kann man auch seine Sessions teilen, aber
ich finde das mit T-Max ist viel angenehmer. So, habe ich jetzt schon rebooted Leute? Ich
glaube, ich habe rebooted schon, ja. Gibt es einen guten T-Max Guide? Ja, es gibt jede
Menge YouTube Videos. So, genau, dann machen wir jetzt mal folgendes. Eine Sache, die ich
mir nie merken kann und ich glaube, ich werde sie mir auch nie merken können, ist folgendes,
Add User vs User Add, weil da waren sie besonders benutzerfreundlich wieder unter Debian. Das
ist so ein Debian Ding. Es gibt sowohl den Befehl Add User und es gibt auch den Befehl
User Add. Was meint ihr, was der Unterschied ist? Kann man nicht wissen, kann man nicht
wissen, wenn man das noch nicht hatte. Also, das eine, das eine ist der eigentliche Befehl
zum User anlegen. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Chat, ja, einer hat es richtig, einer hat es richtig
im Chat. Deine macht ein Homp-Verzeichnis auch richtig. Ne, das ist auch keine, also
es sind beide zum User anlegen, aber das eine und ich kann mir nie merken welcher, das eine
ist der ursprüngliche Befehl zum User anlegen und das andere ist ein Skript um diesen User
anlegen Befehl, der dich noch fragt so nach dem Motto, wie ist der Vorname des Users, leg
dein Heimatverzeichnis an, lässt dich ein Passwort vergeben. Also im Prinzip ist es
den, den man will. Genau, User Add ist native, binary, bla, bla, bla, Add User ist a more
friendly Skript. Also wir wollen Add User haben, wir wollen nicht User Add haben. Das
ist also, beschissenere Benamung hätte nicht sein können. Es ist halt hochgradig benutzerfreundlich
gerade. Also Add User wollen wir haben. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt Add User Max,
dann fragt der mich nämlich auch, also dann sagt er erstmal, ha, ich leg ne neuen User
an, Max mit der ID sowieso, ich mach ein Heimatverzeichnis, ich kopier die Standard Bash RC und sowas
rein und jetzt kann ich ein Passwort auswählen. So und das macht alles dieses Skript für
mich und User Add legt wirklich nur den User an, ohne Heimatverzeichnis, ohne Passwort,
ohne alles. Das heißt, du musst das, was dieses Skript macht, danach von Hand machen, was
total beknackt ist, deswegen macht jeder, der noch normal im Kopf ist, Add User anstatt
User Add. So und ich muss mir jetzt ein Passwort ausdenken, wo ihr nicht drauf kommt, weil
man kann sich auf dem Server einloggen dann mit dieser Kiste. Also, ich brauch mal irgendein
sinnvolles Passwort überlegen. Ok. New Passwort. Nein, ich hab mein Passwort geleakt. Kepopock
2020. Ok, da brauch ich ein anderes Passwort. Try again, yes, yes, yes, try again, yes.
I'm in. Hacker, Hackermans sind schon am Start. Ok. Aha, aha. Aha, so, jetzt ist das Passwort
angegeben. Jetzt fragt er mich noch so Zeug ab wie Fullname, Roomwork, das braucht eigentlich
kein Mensch. Is information correct? Yes. So und jetzt ist das Ganze angelegt. Und jetzt
reboot ich mal, falls der Chat schneller war als ich und dort mit dem User irgendwas gemacht
hat, was eigentlich nicht sein kann, weil der User ein leeres Passwort hatte und User mit
leerem Passwort standardmäßig nicht einloggen dürfen, aber man weiß ja nie, im Chats sind
da die ultra krassen Hackermans, da muss man ja aufpassen. So, jetzt hat er den User angelegt
und jetzt kann ich mich auch mal als dieser User hier einloggen. Wir sehen, dass keiner
was getrieben hat oder hat die Historie gelöscht. So, mit dem User machen wir jetzt weiter.
Also ich bin da kein großartiger Fan von sich direkt als Root einzuloggen. Es ist natürlich
praktisch, aber viele Services mögen das nicht unbedingt direkt als Root gestartet
zu werden. Ich glaube, Docker meckert mittlerweile auch. Zumindest ist das nicht so schön. Und
sollte man mal wirklich in irgendeiner Art und Weise angreifbar sein, ist es doof, wenn
es direkt als Root läuft. Docker versus Portman. Habe ich keine großartige Meinung zu, weil
ich habe Portman kaum verwendet. Was war nochmal die Existenzberechtigung für Portman? Ich
habe es schon wieder vergessen. Das ist genau, dass du keinen Docker Demon mehr brauchst
oder so. Irgendwie sowas. Also das Beste ist, wenn du einen trollen willst, wirklich Immutable
auf irgendeinen File zu machen, dann blickt keiner mehr durch. So, ja, auch noch eine
wichtige Geschichte, die man immer machen muss, falls der Chat auch gerade schreibt.
Der Chat hat Recht. Eine Sache, die ich immer mache, ist, egal wo, HIST-Size, erstmal ein
paar Nullen dran hängen. Ich weiß, man kann das Ganze ausschalten, aber da weiß ich immer
nicht, wie. Das heißt, meine HIST-Size ist quasi nahezu unlimitiert jetzt. So, aber
jetzt kommen wir zur eigentlichen Sache, was wir machen müssen ist. Ich installiere mir
mal einen Docker. Braucht man nicht, wie gesagt, ich bin ja auch immer dafür, dass man nicht
unnötig viel verkontainerisiert, was nicht unbedingt sein muss. Aber ich glaube jetzt
hier zum Ausprobieren ist das eigentlich mal gar nicht verkehrt. Und dann stellen wir
den Default-Editor um. Und dann editieren wir die Sudo-Auf-File und stellen Root-Login
ab. Eigentlich hätte ich das zuerst machen können. Docker installieren ist total unwichtig
jetzt erstmal. Also jetzt erstmal den Default-Editor umstellen und erstmal gucken, ob ich einen
kompletten Wim installiert habe oder nicht. Weil Debian ist ja der Meinung, dass der Default-Editor
Nano ist. Und Nano ist Paints-Champ. Deswegen sagen wir Update Alternatives-Editore-Konfig-Editore.
Ja genau. Und da wählen wir jetzt Wim aus. Sehr gut. Und wenn man jetzt ein Befehl zum
editieren von der Datei aufmacht, dann geht es mit Wim auf. Das heißt, man hat auch gleich
einen ordentlichen Editor. Das stimmt, ich finde es nicht verkehrt, dass es Nano ist.
Ubuntu hat ja so den Ruf, dass es eines der einsteigerfreundlichsten Sachen ist. Und man
muss auch sagen, Ubuntu selber finde ich ist auch ziemlich einsteigerfreundlich. Gerade
die ganze Paketauswahl, diese Sachen hier mit etc-defaults und... Also Ubuntu macht es
schon ganz gut. Aber trotzdem... Also deswegen kann ich auch verstehen, dass Nano defaultmäßig
dabei ist. Aber ich komme mit Nano nicht klar. Ich brauche einen ordentlichen Wim auf dem
Server. Ich kann Nano schlicht und greifend auch gar nicht richtig bedienen. Also was
wichtig ist, dass das hier drin steht, aber das ist schon drinne. Also sprich alle User,
die in der Sudo-Gruppe sind, die dürfen alles im Endeffekt. Das heißt, was ich jetzt mache
ist User Mod und ich füge mal meinen Max-User in die Sudo-Gruppe hinzu und auch gleich mal
in die Docker-Gruppe, dass ich das drauf zugreifen darf. Dann mache ich noch eine weitere Sache.
Ich logge mich noch mal per SSH ein, allerdings nach ssh-copy-id und zwar jetzt mit meinem
neuen User, dass mein SSH-Key da draufkommt. Ich kann natürlich auch den SSH-Key von root
kopieren, ist kein Problem, aber so ist einfacher. Das mache ich übrigens alles, bevor ich Passwort-Authentifizierung
und Root-Login abschalte, weil sonst kann ich mich danach nicht mehr einloggen. SSH, zack, funktioniert.
Jetzt können wir hergehen, können sagen ccc, ssh, sshd und jetzt stellen wir Root-Login aus.
Ich glaube übrigens, es reicht, wenn man es auskommentiert, aber ich treffe jetzt einfach mal
ein, kein Root-Login und kein Passwort und keine Passwort-Authentifizierung, no. So,
stemctl, restart, sshd. Und eine Sache, die ich auch immer empfehlen kann, wenn man sowas
macht, testet das nie im gleichen Fenster. Ja, Matt, das ist nicht schlimm. Testet das nie im gleichen
Fenster, weil ich habe jetzt hier noch eine SSH-Verbindung und bin mit Root eingeloggt. Das heißt,
ich könnte hier alles wieder rückgängig machen, wenn ich es verkackt habe. Das heißt, man nimmt
immer eine zweite Session und guckt, ob es funktioniert. Wie oft habe ich mich schon ausgesperrt
auf irgendeinem System, weil ich Kacke gebaut habe und bin dann immer drauf gekommen. Es gibt
so ein paar Sachen, da gewöhnt man sich mit der Zeit dran. Ja. Und jetzt sehen wir, dass alles
funktioniert. Jetzt passt. Jetzt kann ich beide Sessions mal auflassen und mir das angucken. Aber
mach das nie mit der gleichen Session, weil stell dir euch mal vor, ich hätte es jetzt verkackt,
hätte mich ausgeloggt und hätte mich nicht mehr einloggen können. Klar, ich hätte immer noch
über die Server-Konsole hier gehen können. Das ist eigentlich beknackt. Ja, das ist richtig.
So. Ich will auch ehrlich gesagt auch gar keinen Docker drauf nutzen, aber ich habe mir gedacht,
das ist zum Ausprobieren ganz praktisch, weil ich weiß nicht, ob ich da irgendwas, ich wüsste nicht,
was ich da drauf verdockerisieren möchte. Aber zum Ausprobieren ist eigentlich ganz nett. Und
übrigens, eine Sache ist ziemlich doof gelöst. Was jetzt mit dem Cloud Server gemacht wird,
das verwende ich für meine Presence Detection. Weiß ich, ob ich genau den verwende, vielleicht
Löcher stehen auch nochmal. Es gibt eine Sache, die ist ziemlich doof gelöst unter Ubuntu und im
Zusammenarbeit, also Docker und Ubuntu. Obwohl es ist bei Red Hat übrigens genauso, es ist eigentlich bei
allen Distributionen so. Wenn man in Docker Container startet, wir machen mal jetzt hier einen
Docker Compose Ordner und ich habe irgendwo schon was vorbereitet. Ich weiß es so wie in der
Koch Show jetzt, was wir hier reinkopieren können. Wo habe ich es denn? Ah, hier. Ich habe
schon mal ein Docker Compose File vorbereitet, dass ich was zeigen kann, wo man auch wieder den
Vorteil von Container und Docker Compose sieht. Ich kann jetzt einfach einen File erlegen und habe
da schon ein bisschen Sachen im Vorfeld reingebastelt. Und wenn ich das jetzt, wenn ich das
dann noch richtig schreibe, ausführe, startet er mir einfach zwei Container komplett, so wie
ich es haben will. Funktioniert jetzt allerdings nicht, weil ich verwende hier Domainnamen von mir,
hier QChat und da habe ich die IP noch nicht umgestellt vom Server. Deswegen lösch ich den
ganzen Mist mal und zeige euch mal was anderes, was nicht so schön ist. Und zwar, ich habe hier
oben die Firewall aktiviert. Der startet jetzt so einen Container mit quasi, einfach nur
Hallo Welt, Hallo Welt Container hat er jetzt gestartet. So und jetzt passt mal auf, wenn ich
jetzt auf die Public IP gehe, könnt ihr auch mal ausprobieren, habe ich irgendwas vergessen?
Ah, ich habe die Ports vergessen, kann das sein? Ich habe die Ports vergessen. Ja, ich glaube,
ich habe die Ports vergessen. Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht die UFW, das ist ja gerade das,
was ich euch zeigen will. Moment mal, habe ich die Ports vergessen? Sollen wir noch Ports machen
oder so? Ports, Ports, 80 oder so, weil das ist nämlich gerade das, was ich euch zeigen will.
Wie war die Sonntagsnummer? Ports, Ports, Ports 80, 80, irgendwie so glaube ich. So und die
Sache ist nämlich die, worauf ich eigentlich raus will, ist, dass die Firewall nicht funktioniert.
Das wollte ich euch jetzt eigentlich zeigen, aber irgendwie, what the fuck, habe ich mich
vertippt, ah hier, was ist das für, was ist das für, übrigens nochmal hier, krasse Vim
Hex, wenn man die Sachen jetzt genau zwei Leerzeichen einrücken will, man kann Visual
Block Selection machen in Vim, jetzt wird es wirklich Big Brain, passt mal auf, Block
Selection, Groß I, zwei Leerzeichen machen, Escape drücken und er rückt beide Zeilen ein,
was übrigens glaube ich gar nicht richtig ist, doch, passt so. Was ist der Reverse Proxy
meiner Wahl, also ich mag den hier am liebsten, weil die Config easy ist, Proxy, der hier,
ich mag den hier am liebsten, weil die Config einfach ist. So, habe ich das jetzt richtig
gemacht, ja, so, Port 80, genau, und jetzt, was euch auffällt, guckt mal da, das ist erreichbar,
Leute, seht ihr, der Service ist erreichbar von außen, warum ist der Service von außen
erreichbar, obwohl die Firewall an ist, wie kann das sein, hat da irgendeiner eine schlüssige
Erklärung für, außer dass Ubuntu komische Dinger macht, ja, der Sebaro hat nicht so
recht mit Docker Magic, genau, weil Docker das scheiß egal ist und selbst IP Tables
Regeln macht, also sprich, diese, wie heißt es nicht Universal Firewall, das heißt doch
nicht Ubuntu Firewall, das heißt irgendwie Easy Firewall, ich weiß gar nicht wofür das
U genau steht, was steht UFW, Uncomplicated Firewall, alles klar, ok, Big Brain Firewall
ist das, die ist quasi so ein Aufsatz auf IP Tables und Docker, also IP Tables ist so
quasi die Low Level, also eigentlich nennt sich das ganze NetFilter, NetFilter ist die
Low Level Firewall in Linux, IP Tables ist das offizielle Frontend für NetFilter und
UFW ist nochmal ein Aufsatz auf IP Tables, weil IP Tables kacke zu bedienen ist und
Docker fügt direkt IP Tables ein und benutzt nicht diese UFW Geschichte, das heißt, man
hat jetzt zwar eine Firewall drauf, aber wenn ich euch mal die Regeln zeige, IP Tables
minus V minus L, da seht ihr, WTF, warum hab ich hier 30 Milliarden Firewall Regeln drinne
und das liegt unter anderem einmal an UFW und einmal an Docker, die eigene Sachen da eintragen.
So, das ist natürlich nicht so schön, weil man würde ja eigentlich von ausgehen, wenn
ich einen Container starte auf Port 80 und ich ne Firewall an hab und Port 80 nicht freigegeben
hab, dann geht das nicht, aber es geht, das heißt, das muss man immer im Hinterkopf behalten,
wenn man nen öffentlich erreichbaren System hat, sobald man nen Docker Container startet,
auch mit Firewall an, also mit UFW und mit Firewall D, auch mit Firewall an, sind auf
einmal die Docker Container extern erreichbar, das ist, ja, eigentlich ist das ziemlich low
brain, ich weiß nicht, warum man da, nicht, dass die Fault ein bisschen sicherer gemacht
hat, also Dom PC, was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst Fire, du kannst IP Tables ausschalten
für Docker, aber das ist auch nicht schön, nicht Sinn und Smack. Genau, und das, was
das Blixer da geschickt hat, das ist das, was ich für gewöhnlich dann mache, ich weiß
nicht, ob das Seiteneffekte irgendwie hat, dass das andere Sachen kaputt machen hat,
bisher funktioniert das gut, und zwar kann man das der ganzen Sache abgewöhnen, und
zwar hat hier ein Big Brain Typ auf GitHub ein paar IP Tables, UFW Befehle ausgeklügelt,
wie das Ganze funktioniert, ich hab auch so, ich versuch mal kurz zu erklären, wie das
Ganze funktioniert, so ein bisschen Durchblick, was IP Tables Sachen krieg ich noch zusammen,
aber ich füg das erst mal ein, die After Rules, und das Ganze kommt jetzt hier unten, Set,
Paste, zack. So, also was das Ganze macht ist, übrigens warum Docker da dran vorbeigeht,
ist relativ einfach, wenn ich euch mal die IP Tables Regeln zeige, fangen wir mal oben
an, Input ist erst mal hier interessant, Input und Forward, guckt, Forward ist vor UFW, also
IP Tables handelt das Ganze prinzipiell, gibt es da drei Sachen, oder vier Sachen, machen
wir nur drei Sachen, es gibt Input, das ist alles jeglicher Traffic, der auf den Host
will, es gibt Output, das ist jeglicher Traffic, der nach außen will, und es gibt Forward,
das ist quasi was der Host von einem Interface zum anderen routet, so, und nachdem die Docker
Regeln vor den UFW Regeln sind, greift UFW nicht, es gibt noch NAT Einträge und so,
aber das lassen wir jetzt erst mal weg, so und durch diese Einträge hier macht der Typ
ein bisschen Magic, dass das Ganze doch wieder funktioniert, der erlaubt beispielsweise das
interner Traffic, immer erlaubt es, funktioniert, dann verbietet er, oh das ist jetzt Special,
ich glaube da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen für, also wenn man eine TCP Verbindung aufbaut,
dann hat die verschiedene States, also TCP Verbindung ist ja nicht einfach nur, ich schicke
dir irgendwelche Daten, sondern die machen da am Anfang ja so einen Handshake, also sprich
TCP Verbindung, warte mal, jetzt muss ich auch noch nebenbei ein bisschen Stateful Firewall
erklären, das ist Big Brain Stream heute, also, so, genau, so sieht eine TCP Verbindungsaufbau
aus, also sprich, ich sag zum Server, ich will eine Verbindung aufbauen, der Server sagt
alles klar, ich sag auch noch mal alles klar und dann ist die Verbindung aufgebaut, so
und was das hier macht ist, das sind diese Flex, also sprich, Verbindung beendet, SYN,
Reset, Acknowledged und SYN-AC, das sind die TCP Flex hier unten macht das Ganze noch
mal für UDP, allerdings für Ports zwischen 0 und 32.000 und es funktioniert, so, genau,
so, also IP-Tables durchzuplicken ist nicht ohne, zumindest, wenn man das einfügt, dann
funktioniert es, dann ist Docker dicht, ich reboote mal bei der Gelegenheit, dass das
auch alles greift und dann ist gut, so, genau und jetzt werde ich den Container starten
und wenn wir es sehen, es gibt keinen Zugriff mehr drauf, aber wegen Corona macht man den
Handshake nicht mehr, aber das wäre jetzt etwas, damit das ganze Internet nicht mehr
funktionieren, aber man kann bestimmt irgendwelche anderen Sachen machen, so mit dem Fuß zusammen
oder so, dann TCP Feet Shake oder Elbow Shake, Elbow Touch, genau.
Was ist das mit dem Z-Paste, was du gemacht hast, um was, was ist das mit dem Z-Paste,
was du gemacht hast, um vom einzufügen, achso, du musst in Vim, kannst du, ich mach das
gerade mal, ich mach das gerade mal, wenn du irgendeine Datei in Vim aufmachst und du
willst was reincopy-pasten, sowas hier, dann hast du normalerweise das Problem, wenn du
es copy-pastest, na super, jetzt funktioniert es, ich glaube, ich muss das mit in Vim mit
X-Highlighting machen, dass der das quasi als Input nimmt, so als würdest du es tippen,
das sagt natürlich, also keine Ahnung, so, ne, gehen wir jetzt mal hin, so, also wenn
ich das jetzt hier reinpasten will, guck mal, dann macht er, dann macht er sowas hier, also
tut es so, als würde das tippen, so, und wenn du sagst, Z-Paste, Z-Paste, dann ist ihm das
alles wurscht und dann kopiert es so rein, wie es im Buffer ist, also wenn du längere
Sachen copy-pastest, gerade auch in Yamels oder so, Yamels sehen dann irgendwann so wie
eine Treppe aus, wenn du das einfach nur einfügst, wenn man Z-Paste davor macht, dann geht nicht
so viel kaputt, beim einfügen, das ist besser, so, und wenn ich jetzt den ganzen Kram hier
starte, wenn ich jetzt hier meinen Hallo-Welt-Container starte, dann werdet ihr sehen, auf Port 80
ist er, aber hier läuft nichts mehr, ich mach's mal zu, aber hier geht nichts mehr, so muss
das sein, also sprich jetzt ist das, jetzt ist das Ganze auch wirklich dicht, und wenn
ich jetzt das Ganze, und wenn ich jetzt erlauben will, dass man da drauf zugreift, also ihr
seht, das geht nicht, und wenn ich jetzt, ich muss mich gerade nochmal einloggen, ah
ne, bin ich noch, bin ich nicht, so, und wenn ich jetzt, ich soll mir den Passport eingeben,
ich lass mal das Ganze auf hier unten, so, und wenn ich jetzt den Port freigebe, dann
seht ihr das, das funktioniert, also sprich, jetzt tut die Fireball das, was sie machen
soll, sehr praktische Geschichte, so, also Chat, ihr könnt's ja mal ausprobieren, wenn
ihr diese IP aufmacht, müsstet ihr jetzt diese Hallo-Welt-Geschichte bekommen, klappt das
einfügen dann auch mit P, nein, das klappt nicht, weil P fügt ja den letzten Buffer,
also den letzten internen Copy-Buffer oder Delete-Buffer oder was auch immer, den letzten
geänderten Buffer von Vim ein, P, und das hier hab ich ja in der OS-Zwischenablage von
der Vim nichts weiß, es gibt die Möglichkeit, wenn du ne grafischen Vim hast, seid ihr in
Chat, ja, wenn du ne grafischen Vim hast, kannst du System Clipboard verwenden, aber
das funktioniert natürlich nicht so, es geht aber es funktioniert nicht so ohne weiteres
über SSH, so, und Chat, funktioniert's, Hallo-Welt, ich denk mal, ich denk mal, es wird funktionieren,
1A, sehr gut, so, dann machen wir das ganze mal wieder aus, ich überleg grad, gibt's
noch, gibt's noch irgendwelche Basics, die ich zeigen könnte, ich glaube nicht, genau,
Sternchen, Quotes, Sternchen P, Quotes plus P, das funktioniert aber natürlich nur, wenn
man im Grafisch, also ne Vim mit X Clipboard Support ist, über SSH funktioniert das ohne
weiteres nicht, man kann das irgendwie über SSH mitnehmen, aber das ist mir immer zu
kompliziert, ich copypaste das dann einfach rein, Set, Paste, gut ist.
Wie viel Traffic hast du gerade wegen Viewern, die die Seite anfragen?
Keine Ahnung, aber höchstwahrscheinlich so gut wie nichts, weil das ist einfach nur
Text ohne irgendwas, sieht man das hier irgendwo?
Sieht man irgendwie Networking Traffic oder so?
Also, ne, Chat, ihr habt keinerlei Traffic verursacht, das hätte ich mir jetzt, das
hättet ihr aber schon, ne, also das hätten wir besser hinkriegen können, SSH mal die
Commodite Bots ausholen, rausholen, das geht nicht über Cloudflare, das geht nicht über
Cloudflare, aktuell kommst du direkt auf meinem Headstar Server raus, ohne Cloudflare oder
sonst was.
WireGuard oder OpenVPN, also der Einfachkeit halber würde ich sagen WireGuard.
So, also, nachdem wir jetzt ja nichts wirklich Sinnvolles machen können mit dem System,
wo ich jetzt irgendwie noch Basics zeigen könnte, also mir fällt zumindest nichts ein.
Chat, fällt euch noch irgendwas ein, was ich Basics-mäßig Linux zeigen soll, ansonsten
würde ich jetzt mal ein paar Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate machen über Docker, so, dass man mal sieht,
wie einfach das gehen kann, wenn man SSL-Zertifikate haben will.
Tja, aber das ist eigentlich nur die Basics, die ich auf dem System mache, also es ist
nicht viel, Prinzip erst mal ein Upgrade, Firewall einschalten und SSH Passport login
ausschalten, fertig.
Mehr nicht.
Und natürlich Route Login ausschalten, SSH Login, also Passport Login ausschalten, Route
Login ausschalten und das Ding aktualisieren, Firewall einschalten und gut.
FireGuard als Reverse-Proxy drauf, nee, ich glaube FireGuard und Reverse-Proxy wird nicht
großartig funktionieren.
Reverse-Proxy kannst du ja nur HTTP und FireGuard wird keine HTTP sein.
Kannst du ein Speedtest zielern?
Ist das hier drauf?
Ist das?
Alter, siehst du?
Okay, das kann man erzählen.
Okay, wir machen mal ein Speedtest.
Wir machen Speedtest mal von der Hetzener Kiste.
Speedtest.
Schauen wir mal.
Oh, das geht aber zackig.
Exzellent.
Na ja, da geht doch noch mehr.
Nur ein halbes Gigabit.
Was soll ich machen?
Speedtest, Minusminus, List.
Und dann?
Es werden zurzeit keine Streams in meinem Archiv angezeigt.
Doch.
Doch, doch.
Werden.
Hier geht es zur Übersicht und dann gehst du in den Ordner rein und dann hast du alle
Streams.
Was geht da nicht?
Ach, du warst, du warst in dem anderen Archiv.
Ja, das ist nie fertig geworden.
Ich weiß nicht.
Irgendeiner wollte das basteln, aber das hat es nie so weit geschafft, dass es funktioniert
hat.
Und das hat dann nur die Leute verwirrt.
Hallo, warum kann ich kein List machen?
Was soll?
Moment.
Sebaro.
Was soll ich kreppen?
Ness.
Was ist das?
Kenne ich nicht.
Nessum?
Nessus?
Nee, was?
Moment.
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Gibt es nicht, Sebaro.
Gibt es nicht.
Gibt es irgendwas in Frankfurt?
Ah, yes.
Oh, wir gehen mal zur Telekom.
Exzellent.
Wie macht man das hier überhaupt ein?
So?
Nee.
Sebaro?
Ah ja, auf geht's zur Telekom.
Oh, die Telekom ist schneller.
Die Telekom hat vollen Gigabit-Speed hier.
Da flutscht's.
Was?
Idee?
Nee.
PC-lustig, das ist eine geile Idee.
Das ist eine richtig coole Idee.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Warte mal.
Wartet mal.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir machen jetzt einen Speed-Test auf dem Headset, auf den ihr euch connecten könnt.
Das ist eine Poggers-Idee, Alter.
Lieberes Speed.
Moment.
Was war das nochmal hier?
Oh, Moment.
Lieberes Speed.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt aber ordentlich machen, Leute.
Also, wir machen das jetzt, dass man auch noch ein bisschen... Genau, der Adolf Intel,
also der Typ, der Lieberespeed-Typ, der hieß so Adolf Intel Speed-Test.
Bester Name, oder?
Was für ein... Ist das hier Adolf Intel Speed-Test?
Adolf Intel Speed-Test, was die da machen?
Ey, ich kann nix dafür, der Typ heißt halt Adolf Intel, Mann.
Also, wir können auch den... Chat, wir machen das jetzt, dass man dabei was lernt.
Ich lock mich mal nebenbei in Cloudflare ein.
Cloudflare.
Das mache ich aber da, wo ihr nicht zugucken könnt, weil ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob da irgendwas liegt oder sonst was.
Oder login.
Oder ich glaube, man liegt nix.
Liegt man bei Cloudflare irgendwas?
Okay.
Ich mach mal kurz in Cognito-Tab, dass es danach wieder weg ist.
Cloudflare.com.
Jaja, login.
Jetzt muss ich mal einen Keypass aufmachen, sodass ihr nix seht.
Deswegen copypaste ich da jetzt auch nix.
Cloudflare.
Ach so, nee.
Ich kann es euch nicht zeigen, Chat.
Ich kann es euch nicht zeigen.
Ich muss euch leider, leider ausblenden.
Manchmal ist zu viel Technik auch nicht gut, weil ich kann jetzt das Passwort nicht copypaste.
Wenn ich jetzt das Passwort copypaste, ist es in meinem Clipboard-Manager drin.
Manchmal ist zu viel, manchmal ist zu viel auch nicht gut.
DNS, okay, exzellent.
Okay, ich mach euch wieder an.
Deswegen kein Clipboard-Manager.
Ja, das bringt es natürlich auch.
So, hier sind wir bei Cloudflare.
Jetzt können wir eine neue Domain anlegen.
Weil eben jemand gefragt hat...
Irgendwas mit Cloudflare.
Was kann Cloudflare in der Free-Version alles?
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich es nicht, was die alles können.
Ich verwende nur den DNS davon.
So, Q-Chat, MQTT, also was legen wir für ein DNS-Eintrag an?
Komm, wir nehmen Q-Chat.
Wobei Q-Chat, der braucht dann ein bisschen zum Bearbeiten.
Q-Chat, wir nehmen Q-Chat, besser.
Speedtest, Q-Chat.
Gut, bearbeiten, dann kommt die neue IP rein.
Das da, exquisite IP.
Wieder, zack, speichern.
Okay, sehr gut.
Jawoll.
So, und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, dass das Ganze aktualisiert.
Ich schieb das mal weg.
Schauen wir mal, ping, ping, Q-Chat, Punkt.
Okay, löst schon mal richtig auf, alles gut.
Gehen die Subdomains dann auch nur über den Cloudflare-DNS oder tragen die das auch in alle anderen ein?
Also ich hab so, dass ich verwende die Domain ja hauptsächlich intern.
Ich hab das bei mir lokal auf dem DNS eingetragen, das meiste.
Ich mein, du kannst den Cloudflare natürlich eintragen, hier Server102.168.11 oder so.
Aber da muss ich jedes Mal zum Cloudflare-DNS, wozu?
So, also, unsere Domain löst auf.
Ping, Q-Chat, Punkt, Maus, Punkt, Maus, Punkt, Haus, funktioniert.
Ähm.
So, und jetzt legen wir mal was an.
Und zwar, wir wollen ja, dass der Speedtest auch mit SSL-Zertifikaten und mit TLS funktioniert.
So, und wie wir das machen ist, dann nehm ich noch mal die Config, die ich hier eben schon mal reinkopypastet hat.
Und dann erklär ich die Config mal, bevor ich's jetzt einfach nur hier reinschmeiße und nix is.
Send-Paste.
So, zack.
Also, was das macht ist folgendes.
Das installiert ein Reverse-Proxy.
Welche Server hat wir benutzt du denn zu Hause?
Äh, das ist, ich hatte mal davor so ne übertrieben, ähm, Auferseiste, 4HE, 8-Core-Kiste.
Hab ich jetzt weggeschmissen und hab ne ultra-low-power, 4-Kern-Intel-X86-Kiste.
Reicht für alles, was ich machen will.
Ich hab auch das ganze ZFS-Raid und Gedöns rausgeschmissen.
Einfach nur noch eine SSD und eine 12TB-Platte dran und gut ist.
Ich hab, äh, massig downgraded.
So, also ich installier jetzt ein Reverse-Proxy drauf, der für mich das Handling von den SSL-Zertifikaten macht.
Und zwar, ich sag ihm hier, ähm, das ist egal, Debug-Ausgabe, sonst was.
So, ich sag, Port 80, Port 443.
Logischerweise, weil Port 80 HTTP und Port 443 SSL, HTTPS.
Dann mach ich den Redirect, also sprich, wenn man auf die Domain geht,
mit HTTP wird man automatisch redirected auf HTTPS.
Ähm, dann braucht man das hier für Zertifikate.
Der verwendet, um Zertifikate auszustellen, die standardmäßig hatte,
die standardmäßige HTTP-Challenge von Let's Encrypt.
Let's Encrypt kann zwei Challenges, eigentlich können sie drei, aber realistisch benutzt werden plus zwei.
Ähm, DNS und HTTP.
DNS funktioniert folgendermaßen, ähm, man hinterlegt auf dem DNS quasi, ich sag mal,
ich nenn's mal so ein geheimes, geheimen Key und Let's Encrypt fragt dann deinen DNS ab
und wenn es den geheimen Key findet, den nur Let's Encrypt kennen kann,
dann bist du der rechtmäßige Eigentümer dieser Domain und, äh, dann kriegst du ein Zertifikat.
HTTP-Challenge funktioniert ähnlich, plus mit dem Unterschied,
dass das über eine öffentliche Webseite ausgetauscht wird, also sprich,
die machen eine statische Webseite, wo das, wo dieser geheime Key drauf steht
und, äh, dann rufen sie das über einen Webserver ab.
So, äh, dann passt so.
Das handelt alles Traffic für mich.
Traffic ist ehrlich gesagt, äh, ne, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen eine kacke Software,
weil die funktioniert ziemlich gut, ist eine, äh, Software mit ziemlich eklicher Config.
Also, das hätte man viel einfacher machen können.
Traffic Config.
Das Schöne ist, dass Traffic, äh, ziemlich gut integriert ist, was Docker angeht.
Der erkennt alle Docker-Container automatisch, die ich laufen hab
und, äh, kann die reverse proxien.
So, dementsprechend kann ich jetzt auch, wenn ich, äh, einen neuen Container anlegen will,
übrigens, ich hab hier noch einen Basic-Auth drauf,
das mach ich dann gleich aus, wenn alles funktioniert, äh,
deswegen kann ich hier auch relativ einfach sagen, okay, ich will einen neuen Service anlegen
und, ähm, sobald ich ihm sage, hier, guck mal, Service bekommt diese Domain,
dann muss ich sonst nichts machen,
Traffic nimmt automatisch für diese Domain ein neues, äh, ein neues Zertifikat aus und gut ist.
Also, ich kann quasi jetzt, ähm, wenn ich, wenn ich das alles ordentlich hinterlegt hab,
kann ich quasi 30 Services anlegen mit unterschiedlichen Domains,
solange der DNS richtig konfiguriert ist.
Also, ich würde dann einfach einen Wildcard machen um DNS irgendwie und sagen hier alles auf den Server
und dann könnte ich quasi 30 Services reinpasten
und er wird mir 30 Zertifikate ausstellen. Ziemlich einfach.
So, allerdings wollen wir jetzt hier keinen WhoAmI-Container, wir probieren mal aus,
ob es funktioniert mit dem WhoAmI-Container, ähm,
und wir wollen ja einen Speedtest, den der Chat ausprobieren kann,
da machen wir ein bisschen Traffic bei Hetzner gleich.
Okay, wir schauen mal, ob das Ganze jetzt funktioniert.
Von der Idee her sollte jetzt folgendes passieren.
Er sollte zwei Container starten, ähm, nämlich einmal den Reverse-Proxy-Container
und einmal diesen Hallo-Welt-Container.
Er sollte jeglichen Traffic umleiten, von HTTP zu HTTPS.
Ähm, er sollte sich ein Zertifikat ausstellen für Q-Chat
und äh, er sollte diesen Container hier starten und Traffic darauf weiterleiten.
Gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
So, Docker-Compose, wir machen erstmal das alte, ups, das alte weg.
So, Docker-Compose ab.
Normalerweise macht man Minus-D, dass das Ganze im Hintergrund gestartet wird,
aber ich mach's mal ohne Minus-D, dass man sieht, was er, was er so, was er so, so treibt.
So, da startet er erstmal Traffic-Container, dann startet er den WhoAmI-Container.
So, oh, und jetzt macht er neue Zertifikate.
Looking for provided certificate, bla, bla, bla, äh, needed certificate,
und ihr seht, der stellt jetzt ein neues Zertifikat aus.
Im Hintergrund.
So, und der müsste jetzt eigentlich auch fertig hier.
Validation success, also sprich, der hat ein neues Zertifikat bekommen.
Q-Chat.mau.house. Probieren wir mal aus.
Äh.
Ah, wisst ihr, warum es nicht geht?
Chat, wer hat aufgepasst, warum geht's nicht?
Ich muss Port 443 noch freigeben, lul.
Und jetzt Basic Auth, bam.
Ja, das ist absichtlich drauf.
Äh, damit ihr erstmal nichts machen könnt.
So, ihr seht, funktioniert.
Zertifikat ausgestellt, alles gut.
Ich seh schon, ich seh schon.
Jaja, Jaja, Chat, ist gut.
So, wir machen mal wieder zu.
Dass der Chat sich nicht zu sehr austoben kann.
Der Chat ist schon wieder dabei.
So, und jetzt legen wir mal den Speedtest-Container an.
Lul, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Okay.
Ähm, Speedtest.
Also, wir machen den, ich mach erstmal down.
Alles wieder weg.
Chat, Chat, ihr könnt nicht in sein.
Der Service ist schon längst wieder gestoppt.
Äh, kann man so LDAP verbinden?
Ich glaube, standardmäßig, oder hat er?
Ich weiß nicht, ob er standardmäßig LDAP hat.
Anscheinend kann er standardmäßig auch LDAP.
Aber es gibt ein Modul, was die Alternifizierungssachen weiterleiten kann an den anderen Server.
Spätestens damit kannst du alles alternifizieren, was es gibt.
He doesn't know.
Doch, Chat, ich knowe.
Ich knowe.
Und ich weiß, dass der Chat nicht in ist.
So, also.
Noch mal weiter.
Speedtest für den Chat wollte ich starten, genau.
Also, wir machen jetzt mal den MI-Container, machen wir mal weg.
Jetzt können wir übrigens wieder Big-Brain-Docker-Vim-Auskommentiert-Taktik verwenden.
Zack.
Ist das nicht geil?
Ja, ich zeig's euch nochmal hier.
Big-Brain.
Also, man drückt Steuerung V.
Steuerung V ist Visual Block Select.
Also, da kann man sowas hier machen.
So, ne?
Dann selecte ich quasi alles, wo ich auskommentieren will.
Dann drücke ich Großes I.
Großes I wendet den Insert auf alle Selected-Zeilen an.
Groß I.
Da mach ich die Klammer, äh, die Raute.
Dann drücke ich Escape und dann wende das an auf alle, auf alle Sachen.
Excellent.
Exquisite.
Vim.
Logik.
Taktik.
So, und jetzt werden wir mal den Adolf Intel starten.
Und ja, der heißt so.
Vor allem, wenn echt welche Leute ankommen.
So, Adolf Intel starten wir jetzt.
Wie, wie startet man Adolf Intel?
Am besten jetzt im Docker-Compose-File.
Hat er irgendwie irgendein Doku, was man da anmachen muss?
Oder so.
Vielleicht heißt er auch A-D-O.
Le Fintel.
So, ich probier das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Äh, ich kopier das hier mal.
Ups.
Ah, ist okay.
Äh, ich kopier das hier mal.
Dann...
Machen wir hier die Comments mal wieder weg.
Äh, und bis wo muss ich denn einrücken? Bis hier hin?
Äh, bis, bis wo muss ich denn einrücken?
Äh, da hin? Ja.
So, das werden wir nicht whale-mal, sondern Speedtest.
Image.
Image ist das da.
Containername ist Speedtest.
Und ich hoffe mal, das reicht jetzt.
Mal gucken, ob das genug ist.
Mal gucken, ob das reicht.
Mach noch Ports.
Äh...
Ja, Ports, äh...
Muss ich für OMI auch nicht machen, Ports.
80.
80, 80.
Oder so.
Du musst Basic Auth ausmachen. Nee, muss ich nicht.
Ich muss erst mal gucken, ob es funktioniert, bevor ich Basic Auth ausmache.
So, und jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das, ob das klappt.
Docker Compose ab.
Äh, ups.
Ohje, ich hab was verkehrt gemacht. Ich muss erst mal kurz Musik restarten.
Ja, eigentlich hätt ich auch gehört, dass ich keine Ports maus.
Was hab ich denn verkehrt gemacht?
Man darf auch sagen, dass es immer noch Who Am I heißt, was aber kein Problem sein sollte.
Unsupported Config Options.
Hä?
Hab ich mich irgendwo falsch eingerückt?
Ah, Moment, ich kann nicht Port 80, 80 machen, dass ich schwachsinn.
Äh, nee, nee, nee, keine Ports.
Aber...
Wo ist das Problem?
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Alles unter Speedtest ist zu weit eingerückt.
Hä?
Ah!
Oh, Jammel, Alter.
Jetzt.
Jetzt ist es okay hier, guckt.
Jetzt passts.
Okay.
Also, bam.
Adolf Intel Speedtest.
So, jetzt...
Der lädt erstmal das halbe Internet für so ein Speedtest runter.
Chet, wart ihr das?
Warum der so viel runter lädt?
Gibts zu, Chet.
Ach so, ähm...
Ähm, ähm, ähm...
Chet.
Okay, Speedtest funktioniert.
Einmal Speedtest.
Okay, Chet.
So, und ich mach jetzt Basic Auth.
Ich mach jetzt Basic Auth aus.
Und dann könnt ihr mal ausprobieren.
Dann könnt ihr mal ausprobieren.
Chet, stopp, ich mach jetzt erstmal aus.
Ihr könnt noch gar nicht drauf zugreifen, weil Basic Auth ist.
Ich mein, das Passwort,
es sei denn, ihr habt das Passwort rausgekriegt,
das ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert gewesen.
So, äh...
Ja, Basic...
Basic Auth kommt weg.
Okay, Chet.
Jetzt könnt ihr. Auf geht's.
Okay, ähm...
Schauen wir mal, ob's Traffic verursacht.
Also, Chet, komm mal hier.
Ist ja nix.
Schauen wir mal Live-Stats.
Wo ist Live-Stats?
Sebaro?
Was? Crafts?
Ah.
Oh. Leute, wir sind am Anschlag.
CPU-Leistung.
Mehr geht nicht.
Wir sind am Anschlag,
was CPU-Leistung angeht.
Guck mal.
Okay, ich mach mal die Debug.
Moment, Leute, stopp, stopp.
Ich mach mal die Debug-Ausgabe aus.
Ich glaub, wir...
Ich glaub, das braucht so viel,
weil ich so viel, so viel, so viel
rausschreibe.
Wart mal, ich mach mal die Debug-Ausgabe.
Debug, jetzt könnt ihr...
Ihr könnt gleich noch mal.
Äh, Moment, was mach ich denn?
Hier, Debug.
Debug-Ausgabe kommt weg.
Okay, what?
Ach, macht er das immer?
Okay, ich mach noch mal aus, ich mach noch mal aus
und mach Hintergrund und dann sollte aber
nichts mehr passieren.
Ich mach jetzt nämlich
Docker-Compose ab minus D
und
dann, dann sollte es eigentlich passen.
So, H, stopp.
So, Chat, jetzt, jetzt aber.
Äh...
Hahahaha
Äh, da ist, jetzt ist vorbei.
So, wir gucken mal, wieviel
Traffic, wir gucken, wieviel Traffic
der Chat, der Chat macht.
Ja...
Ja, also, komm, also...
So, da ist ja kaum was.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob wir das Ding
gailen können?
Wartet mal, wartet mal, kann man das
upgraden?
Kann man das
upgraden on the fly?
Wartet mal.
Kann man das on the fly
upgraden?
Ah, CPUs?
Wo könnte man das machen?
Rescale?
Ah, ah...
Okay, also, machen wir mal, machen wir mal
ein bisschen mehr. Gucken wir mal.
Kann ich ihn verkraften, Chat?
Bam.
Nee, komm, wir
übertreiben es mal nicht.
Komm, wir machen es.
Äh, was ist überhaupt der Unterschied?
Drei? Also, wir sind auf jeden Fall
CPU gebunden und nicht so sehr
RAM, würde ich sagen.
Okay. Server needs to
be powered down.
Ja, okay.
Äh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Power off.
Dann machen wir kurz aus und machen wir gleich nochmal an.
Das nicht.
Okay.
Ach, ich war hier oben, ich war hier oben nicht gut.
Ah, jetzt.
So, Server, Server aus.
So, was aus.
Rescale.
Und jetzt rescale wir mal.
Ähm.
Ist derjenige, der bei Hetzner Arbeit noch da?
Darf man so was überhaupt?
So mutfällig sinnlos Traffic verursachen?
Ja gut, warum nicht? Ich meine, ich bezahle
den Grams ja im Endeffekt auch.
Ist ja Geld, ne?
Ähm.
Okay, Chat, wir probieren
jetzt mal was aus.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Wir rescalen jetzt mal.
Ich meine, es sind 57 Euro im Monat.
Das kostet ja nicht viel.
So, rescale.
Bam.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was da alles geht, Chat.
Dann rescale mal Hetzner.
Okay.
Post-Jam.
Okay, ich glaube,
er entweder aktualisiert die Webseite nicht
oder es dauert einfach ein bisschen, bis es rescaled ist.
Gibt es einen CLI-Libre-Speed-Client?
Bestimmt.
Im Zweifelfall geht das wahrscheinlich über Curl oder so.
Muss jetzt, muss jetzt ein Admin
ins RZ.
Nee, Quatsch.
Also bei uns,
bei mir auf der Arbeit,
ich kann mir das so richtig vorstellen,
wenn wir sowas anbieten würden,
was natürlich nicht passt, ja.
Unser Außendienst braucht keine Server
und wir sind keine Hoster.
Wenn wir auf der Arbeit sowas anbieten würden,
wir würden es Cloud nennen.
Aber jedes Mal,
wenn eine CPU erweitert,
müsste einer ins RZ rennen.
Oh, Chat.
Wir sind, wir sind drin.
Wir sind drin.
Ihr könnt noch nicht feuern.
Docker, nee,
Docker, Compose,
Compose.
Ich muss erst einmal,
die Auslastung anschmeißen.
So, Docker, Compose, ab.
So, Chat.
Auf gehts.
Gib ihm.
Na also, komm.
Guck mal hier, sind nicht immer ausgelastet.
Wo war das, Crafts?
Oh.
Wann aktualisiert sich das hier unten
einmal am Tag?
Oh.
Und Chat, ist jetzt schneller bei euch.
Ja.
Aber mir ist, sag ich.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt gehts ganz gut hier.
Jetzt, jetzt gehts ganz gut.
So, und wie siehts aus,
CPU-Auslastungstechnisch?
Ja, also die Kiste kann ordentlich was ab.
Oh.
Da hat jetzt aber mal einer gekackt, kann ordentlich drauf gehauen.
Aber Chat,
die Kiste kriegen wir nicht ausgelastet.
Okay.
Ja, nice, Chat.
Ich mach mal wieder aus.
Und ich downscale mal wieder.
Weil ich hab keinen Bock, 50 Euro im Monat zu bezahlen.
Oh ne, PC los.
Ich hab's zu spät gesehen, ich hab's schon ausgemacht.
So.
Ein nicer Test.
So, warte mal.
Power off.
So.
Wobei.
Ich kann einfach, wisst ihr was?
Bam.
Lul.
Einfach so ausschalten.
So, und jetzt rescale,
jetzt rescalen wir noch mal.
Rescalen.
Das lohnt sich nicht, Basti.
Bitcoin zum einen da drüber,
ist absolut komplett
unwirtschaftlich und unsinnig.
Das kostet viel zu viel.
Mittlerweile gibt es
viele von diesen Krypto-Miner-Boxen.
Relativ günstig.
Weil die Leute, die jetzt
gerade mit's loswerden wollen.
Und ich hab ein Video geguckt von einem,
der hat versucht mit
Solar-Panels im Garten
Bitcoin zu minen und so,
so Miner,
so Hardware-Miner-Kisten,
die er sich bei eBay gekauft hat.
Und er ist, glaub ich, ungefähr auf
100 am Tag gekommen.
Und wohlgemerkt, wenn die ganze Zeit
die Sonne scheinen würde.
Lohnt sich also,
lohnt sich also echt nicht.
Aber das ist eine coole Funktion,
dass du in einem bestehenden System
Upcrayen und Downcrayen kannst.
Auf der anderen Seite,
wenn man weiß, dass da KVM drunter ist,
ist da einfach nur eine clevere
Automatisierung dahinter.
Das ist mit KVM ja nicht das Ding.
Du hängst einfach die Platte ab
und legst eine neue Vm an
mit der neuen Hardware.
Oder kannst du auch die alte Vm modifizieren.
Ich geh mal davon aus, dass sie KVM verwenden.
Zumindest
ist das
Dings Analysetool da,
was man unter Ubuntu ausführen kann,
unter Unterlegungsauswirkern der Meinung,
es wäre KVM. Und das ist eigentlich
relativ gut, weil das erkennt zuverlässig
ESXe und KVM.
Natürlich, wenn man jetzt irgendwie
versucht,
einen ESX
als KVM erscheinen zu lassen,
da kann man es bestimmt verarschen.
Hast du direkt eine
Abrechnung?
Naja, ich würde mal sagen, mich hat das
nicht wirklich was gekostet,
außer hochgerechnet
2,89 Monat,
großartig.
Also anteilmäßig auf die paar
Minuten, mich wird das jetzt, keine Ahnung,
2 Cent gekostet haben oder so.
Was, paar Cent
standen da? Wo stand das?
Wo stand was? Stand hier?
Overview?
Price?
Das ist die Startseite hier.
Wo steht da was von Cent?
Ach hier, guck mal, 1 Cent hat es gekostet.
Und wir haben, guck mal, Chet, Chet,
ihr habt nicht mal, ihr habt nicht mal
einen Terabyte geschafft.
Pains Champ.
Hättest du jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
ihr kriegt das besser hin.
Nee, nee, ich hab absichtlich abgeschaltet.
Ich wollte jetzt da nicht unnötig
viel, viel Traffic machen.
So, jetzt ist das Ganze rescaled.
Also gefällt mir gut, also
es hat eigentlich gar keinen
Sinn, da jetzt irgendwie zu Digital
Ocean zu gehen und es doppelt
zu bezahlen. Ich sehe jetzt
da zumindest für so meine
kleinen Geschichten gar keinen großen Vorteil
mehr drin. Also ich glaube, ich werde in Zukunft
öfters Hetzner Sachen verwenden. Ich habe jetzt
auch schon sonst, jetzt einen ganzen Monat
Zeug laufen gehabt und unsere
Projekt-Server,
den wir da haben,
wo ich ja schon mal erzählt habe, wo wir diese
guten Planungssoftware
programmiert haben mit einem Arbeitskollege zusammen,
der läuft ja auch bei Hetzner.
Aber das ist kein Hex-Hetzner-Cloud,
das ist eine
Softwareauktion gewesen.
Das mit rescale ist, ja ich weiß,
das mit rescale können mehr oder weniger
alle, aber ich finde halt cool, dass das
vom Preis her wirklich günstig
ist. Das nächste Mal, ich schreibe mir das
mal auf, Chet, das nächste Mal
probieren wir aus
dieses 1&1.
Wie hießen die Dinger?
Dieses 1&1, ich habe es jetzt schon
vergessen. Ionos
oder so?
Ja, die probieren wir mal aus,
weil ich bin mal echt gespannt,
was die
bieten für einen Euro im Monat.
Spritscale, da habe ich ja nicht angeguckt.
Die haben
VPS.
Das probieren wir das nächste Mal aus und gucken,
ob das was taugt.
Kann es nochmal auf Statistiken gehen?
Ich meine, wir können Networking gucken, da steht gar
nichts drin.
Gibt es irgendwo
eine
Anzeige, die nicht gerade in Terabyte
ist?
Was auf Networking?
Okay, das hat noch nicht aktualisiert.
Steht das bei
ifconfig?
Ach nee, ich habe ja ausgemacht.
Grip.
Corona.
Übrigens Leute, weil
der Basti gerade sagt, ich muss euch jetzt
mal was erzählen, was bezüglich YouTube.
Ich habe gestern Abend
im Bett gelegen und es ist wirklich
jetzt keine Garantie irgendwie, dass ich das mache.
Ich habe gestern Abend im Bett gelegen und habe mir
überlegt,
es erwartet ja keiner mehr auf YouTube
großartig was.
Und ich habe mir
überlegt, was wäre, wenn ich wirklich,
wenn ich es wirklich schaffen würde,
einen Weihnachtskalender auf YouTube
zu machen. So aus dem Nichts.
Einfach 24 Videos
jeden Tag im Dezember aus dem Nichts.
Rechnet keiner
mehr mit.
Die Sache ist nur die,
ich muss das
irgendwie aufnehmen und ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob ich 24 Ideen habe.
Gaming oder IT-related
alles mögliche.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob ich das mache.
Ich meine, ich habe hier nur noch einen Monat Zeit
für. Also ich habe mir schon überlegt,
ich mache da alle mögliche Dinge.
Zum Beispiel
könnte man durchaus mal irgendwie
servermäßig was zeigen.
Einfach ganz was anderes.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ich mache mal
so ein Reacting-Verarsch-Video.
So irgendwas
total abgedrehtes, wo ich auf was reakte,
wo schon einer reakte, der auf was reaktet.
Und dann am besten muss ich
noch den Famian dazu überreden, dass der dann noch
auf mich reaktet oder so. Und das dann
alles übereinander.
Gartenstellsfalls Informatikmythen.
Ich habe schon ein paar Ideen, aber da kann man jetzt
einfach nicht. Wie gesagt, schwierig.
Also ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, ich könnte
mal ein paar Leute anfragen, wie es aussieht.
Also ich könnte an den Famian,
der ist da denke ich mal dabei.
Der hat zwar keinen Bock, aber wenn ich ihm sage, hier
für so einen Tag Weihnachtskalender
und 5.24
ich glaube schon, da macht er mit.
In Thorsten könnte ich mal fragen, ob der noch mal
ein bisschen Bock hätte.
Die Lösung könnte ich fragen,
ob der Bock hätte, ein Video aufzunehmen.
Oder mal schauen.
Ich kenne ja auch gar nicht
so viele, die angesagt sind auf YouTube,
wo man als großartig was machen könnte.
Sagen wir so, ich kenne
aus der aktiven Zeit zwar
relativ viele Flüchtig, aber
das ist jetzt nicht so Bekanntschaft, wo ich sagen würde,
ich frage jetzt einfach mal, ob wir ein Video aufnehmen wollen.
Ja, mal schauen.
Mal schauen, was wir da machen.
Ja, gab es jetzt
irgendwie ordentliche Abrechnungen, wieviel
Traffic wir wirklich gebraucht haben?
Zockst du zurzeit eigentlich noch irgendwas?
Ja, ich spiele mehr oder weniger so jede
zweite League Pass of Exile.
Kollaboration mit
Semper Video.
Nein, also ich glaube erstens nicht,
dass wir da großartig harmonieren würden
und ich glaube auch nicht, dass er irgendwelche
Kollaborations machen will.
Ihr habt recht,
später ist man immer schlauer. Klar hätte ich
irgendwas mitlaufen lassen können.
Aber ich meine,
warum kann man das hier nicht sehen? Guck mal, das ist ja fast nichts.
Guck mal, hier kaum Traffic.
Da.
Ja.
Einfach mal 1000%, was auch immer.
Den habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich mag Engine X,
aber gerade in Kombination mit
Fahrzeug fand ich Traffic bisher
recht angenehm. Wobei ich halt sagen muss,
die Traffic Config selbst ist
schon ziemlich kacke.
Ich habe es bei mir, also hier
lokal auf dem Server habe ich so, ich habe
quasi alles über
Traffic laufen
bis auf zwei Services,
drei Services,
Home Assistant,
die Kamera und Unify,
bis auf drei Services
und
die muss ich über externe
Traffic Config machen.
Und das ist richtig scheiße.
Also ich fände es ja cool, wenn sie das
Pakati mal hinkriegen,
da eine ordentliche
Docker Integration zu machen.
Ich habe schon ein paar Sachen gesehen, das wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Weil das ist mit Abstand,
wirklich mit Abstand,
mein Lieblings
Reverse Proxy HTTP-Säuber für
kleine Sachen. Also einfacher geht es nicht.
Man muss es noch nicht mal großartig
über den Paket Manager installieren,
sondern kann theoretisch einfach eine Binary runterladen.
Ich weiß, das ist verpönt unter Linux,
aber einfach zum Beispiel ausprobieren, das ist ganz praktisch.
Binary runterladen,
drei Zeilen Config machen und es
proxied. Also das ist
mein absoluter Lieblingssache dafür.
Und wenn nicht, dann Nginx
und Docker halt Traffic.
Hier wäre es aber am liebsten, das gäbe hier eine schöne
Docker Integration für.
Das eine schließt das andere nicht aus.
Also LXC ist ja eh alles.
LXC ist ja eh alles.
Also LXC ist ja das ursprüngliche
Zeug,
diese Nginx Container Kernel Geschichte auch.
Und das hieß ja, das erste
Kommando Zeilentool dafür war glaube ich sogar auch, hieß auch
LXC. Mittlerweile
kam ja Ubuntu um die Ecke und hat
schon als LXC, LXD gemacht.
Das ist aber
würde ich gar nicht so sehr als Konkurrenz
zu Docker sehen.
Sondern
es ist halt
mehr.
Also sprich, Docker ist eher
du willst ein Prozess laufen lassen.
Benutzt nicht alles LXC
im Hintergrund, doch doch.
Wie gesagt, dieses ganze Container Zeug
ist ja alles nicht
viel mehr als
Namespaces im Kernel
und Cgroups im Kernel.
Alles.
Also Opottman, Docker, Kubernetes,
Swarm, LXC,
LXD, es ist unter der Haube alles das
gleiche. Und wenn einer gut C
programmieren kann, oder C++, oder
C Sharp mit Linux, AP was auch immer,
kann der ohne Probleme
selbst einen Linux Container starten.
Ohne Docker, ohne alles. Das geht.
So aber der große Unterschied zwischen LXC,
LXD und Docker ist,
Docker ist hauptsächlich
so eine
Anwendungsvirtualisierung,
also sprich, du startest
einen Prozess, der was machen soll
und gut ist.
Und LXC ist quasi,
du startest ein komplettes Init,
hast da drauf, also LXC
ist, also LXD ist deutlich näher
vom Feeling an der VM dran,
als an der Anwendungsvirtualisierung.
Du hast ein komplettes Userline, du hast
ein SSH Login, du hast ein Init laufen.
Also ein LXD ist quasi ein komplett
verdockerisiertes
System, die zwar den
Hostkernel verwenden, das geht ja nicht anders mit
Container, und Docker ist
in der Regel nur einzelne
Anwendungen. Würdest du sagen,
dass Docker zur Zeit konkurrenzlos ist?
Nö, gar nicht. Docker ist sogar,
wenn überhaupt, ein bisschen
auf dem absteigenden Ast aktuell,
aber es ging
auch ohne Docker. Also alles,
was Docker so mehr oder weniger
erfunden hat, ist mittlerweile
ohne Docker zu
benutzen. Also du kannst
Containers ohne Probleme
starten, verwalten, mit
Default,
Config-File-Format ohne Docker.
Eigentlich
braucht man Docker gar nicht mehr, so wirklich.
Aber ich finde es nach wie vor am angenehmsten.
Das Docker stirbt, Portena wächst, das eine hat
mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun. Ah, okay.
Ja.
Genau, genau.
Podman ist ein bisschen angesagt.
Was mich bei Podman nervt, ist
diese, die Red Hat Typen.
Also ich kenne
niemanden persönlich, der bei Red Hat arbeitet, deswegen
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ich mag
es an sich nicht, aber
wenn man sich
die Talks anguckt auf YouTube, von
Red Hat zu Podman, die machen alle so
einen ultra-arroganten Eindruck.
Weiß nicht, wie ich das anders beschreiben soll.
Ich finde die Docker-Community-Vorträgen
sind deutlich sympathischer als die Podman-Dudes.
Gibt es für Docker eigentlich ein gutes,
nicees Webinterface? Da gibt es ein paar
Sachen, aber ich bin
kein Fan von Webinterfaces, was
das angeht. Also
Portena verwenden die meisten, das gefällt
mir gar nicht. Man kann auch gleich
Proxmox verwenden, da ist
quasi, nee, gut, das ist kein
Docker, da ist
aber Container-Geschichten dabei.
Es gibt, ich habe letztens noch auf
Selfhost etwas gesehen, das ist
auch ganz gut. Ja, es gibt hier Dings,
was du auch machen kannst, ist Cockpit
Project oder so.
Kannst du auch was verwandeln.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich
mag das nicht, Webinterfaces.
Also für diese Sache.
Ich hab nicht prinzipiell was gegen Webinterfaces,
aber gegen Webinterfaces, das
ist nicht meins. Vor allem
in Kombination mit dem Docker-Compose-File
brauchst du halt gar kein Webinterface
mehr. Guck mal, ich mein,
es mag jetzt zwar erstmal ein bisschen
kompliziert aussehen, aber
der Vorteil von so einem
Config-File ist, im Vergleich zu
Webinterface, du kannst dieses Ding
auf irgendeinen
Git pushen oder irgendeinen Backup pushen oder so
und wenn du dein System
wieder herstellen willst, checkst du das
Config-File aus und sagst Docker-Compose
ab und es ist da.
In den Webinterface musst du den ganzen
Kram wieder neu zusammenklicken.
Also mir gefällt so eine Config-
Datei besser als
ein Webinterface. Ich weiß, dass es ein bisschen
Geschmackssache ist und man muss ja auch sagen,
großartig kompliziert
ist es nicht.
Das
einzig ist ja, dass die Traffic-Config hier,
wie sagen sie so schön, pain in the ass
ist.
Wie sorgt man dafür, dass das Image nicht
abstürzt, indem du ordentliche Images
verwendest, die
stabile Software drin damit ausliefern.
Aber ja klar, das kann mal crashen
und du kannst Restart-Options angeben.
Da weiß ich jetzt aber gerade aus dem Kopf nicht,
wie es funktioniert. War das Unless?
Nee, Restart?
Es gibt
ein Beispiel.
Hallo, haben die da mal ein
Example?
Also du kannst angeben,
in diesem Config-File hier.
Wenn ich jetzt mal
ein ordentliches Beispiel
für finden würde,
Restart-Policy, genau.
Hier, Restart-Always kannst du
angeben, genau.
Wenn du das hier angibst,
und also sollte
jetzt dieser Container hier crashen,
starte dann automatisch neu.
Was natürlich nur Sinn macht,
wenn das Ding prinzipiell stabil läuft.
Also wenn du da jetzt
einen Container verwendest, den irgendeiner
mit unstable shit
zusammengestellt hat,
dann hast du davon auch nichts, weil dann startet der
Crash, nach zwei Minuten wieder startet, Crash startet,
das bringt auch nichts.
Aber wenn du was hast, was stabil läuft,
und das aus irgendwelchen Gründen mal
crasht, dann kannst du so was hier
reinschreiben.
Ja.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich
den Server ausgemacht?
Off. Bam.
Und ansonsten ist halt auch die
Sache. Man sollte
sich angucken. Ups, jetzt habe ich
den Server ausgemacht.
Na gut, da lasse ich mal auf. Man sollte
sich schon angucken, was man für Images
verwendet.
Ich finde Docker habe nicht sonderlich übersichtlich.
Aber
wenn man jetzt
zum Beispiel, was nehmen wir jetzt mal?
Was nehmen wir denn mal?
Keine Ahnung, nehmen wir mal
diesen Halo-Welt-Container
als Beispiel. Normalerweise, du sagst
jetzt, ey, ich will diese Sache hier laufen lassen.
Die meisten
Leute am Anfang, wo ich gesehen
habe, ist, die verwenden
dieses Container-Image quasi so
wie hier, ohne Option.
So. Und was
das macht, ist, das verwendet
immer die letzte, immer die letzte Version.
So. Und wenn man
hier hinten kann man Doppelpunkt eine Version
angeben oder irgendeinen Tag. Und das ist
dringend zu empfehlen,
das zu machen,
weil sonst
Upgraded, der dir das Ding im Zweifelsfall unterm Arsch weg,
wenn du da was drin hast. Also wenn
standardmäßig, ohne was anzugeben,
nimmt er immer Latest. Nimmt er immer Latest.
So. Und Latest hast du halt
Sachen, die werden teilweise alle fünf
Minuten mal aktualisiert. So.
Und ich habe meistens noch einen
dritten Containerservice jetzt hier laufen,
wenn ich jetzt hier einen aufmachen kann, der ab und zu mal
die Container aktualisiert.
Auf die aktuelle
jeweilige Release-Version.
Aber wenn du da Latest drinstehen hast im Tag,
dann ist halt
doof.
Dann aktualisiert er dich nämlich auf
Latest mit Bugs oder ohne Bugs.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel
können wir das bei Nextcloud mal angucken.
Die aktualisieren das relativ oft.
So.
Und wenn... Nee, Nextcloud ist doof, weil
die haben einen Release-Tag.
So. Aber hast du zum
Beispiel bei Nextcloud Latest drinstehen,
dann
Upgraded er dir das, wenn du was hast,
was automatisch Upgraded. Und auf einmal
geht der Nextcloud nicht mehr.
Das ist doof.
Deswegen würde ich dann immer sowas hier angeben, entweder
Stable, das da, wenn man eben sagt,
ok, ich will immer aufs aktuelle Stable gehen,
aber ich würde sogar empfehlen, sowas hier
anzugeben in der Richtung.
Weil dann bleibt er immer auf
Version 20, macht
alle Sicherheitsupdates mit,
die in 20 reinkommen.
Allerdings Upgraded nicht auf
21.
Also die Sachen würde ich immer nehmen.
Es gibt ein paar
Container, wo das ein bisschen
wirklich ist. Zum Beispiel
bei
DokuWiki,
die haben es ein bisschen verkackt, wobei ich weiß
gar nicht, ob das der aktuelle DokuWiki ist.
Die haben so komische Tageszahlen,
das ist dann auch ganz,
ganz, ganz wirr. Also da muss
man sich darauf verlassen, dass die Hersteller da
ein ordentliches Tagsystem haben.
Das ist richtig, Docker fetch
doch nur das Image, wenn man es explizit angibt.
Aber wie ich gerade gesagt habe, ich habe
meistens noch sowas hier zum Beispiel
laufen,
was
im Hintergrund die Docker Images aktualisiert
für mich.
Und wenn man da Latest drinstehen hat, ist fatal.
Da guckste drauf und auf einmal geht dein
Zeug nicht mehr.
Ich halte es für sinnvoll,
sowas laufen zu haben. Also der
aktualisiert deine Docker Container.
Einmal alle, je nachdem wie du es
eingestellt hast. Ich halte es
für sinnvoll, sowas laufen zu lassen.
Oh fuck Leute, es ist 22.19
WTF.
Ich muss ins Bett.
Was ist denn da los?
Monka Toss.
Ja, ich mach das noch mal kurz im Schnelldurchgang.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Er hat es gemerkt,
he doesn't know.
He lacked critical information.
Ja genau, also ich habe immer sowas im Hintergrund
noch laufen,
dass die Docker Container aktualisiert. Ich finde es
relativ wichtig, weil
auf der einen Seite sagt man, hey
Docker kannst du total einfach neue Sachen
rein machen, upgraden ist einfach super
toll und dann upgraden die Leute nicht.
Und dann hast du dann irgendwann eine olle Version
mit 20.000 Sicherheitslücken,
weil du nicht abgecreated hast.
Es ist meistens nicht schlimm,
man hat die Sache eh lokal bei sich im Netzwerk
laufen, dann ist es nicht so wild.
Im Docker Container, wenn damals unsicher ist,
ist es vielleicht eh schon nicht ganz so kritisch wie
jetzt irgendwie auf dem Hostsystem, aber trotzdem
ich finde es sinnvoll, dass man die Container im Hintergrund
aktualisiert und deswegen ist wichtig,
dass man ordentliche Tags angibt
bei seinen Containern, weil
ansonsten macht das Ding einen Next Cloud
Major Update oder irgendwas
und es ist kaputt.
KZ, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Excellent
Subscription. Ich hoffe ich habe keine
Subs übersehen heute, ich habe glaube ich
gar nicht richtig geguckt.
Zu beschäftigt
mit Geschwätze.
Das neue Joplin Interface, ja
das sieht hübsch aus, ja.
Also wenn das das ist, was es schon seit zwei Wochen gibt
oder so, dann habe ich das schon gesehen, sieht ganz
hübsch aus, ja.
Gibt es da eine bessere Lösung für Diversionierung?
Ja wie gesagt, die gucken, dass man Container
nimmt, die ein ordentliches Tagsystem haben.
Ja und das
Docker Compose File würde ich in
einem Git Repo oder so einchecken.
Sonst kannst du nämlich auch nachverfolgen, was du
gemacht hast. Kannst du bitte einmal kurz erläutern,
was Docker ist? Da habe ich jetzt keine Zeit
mehr für, aber es gibt einen richtig coolen,
den habe ich letztens gesehen.
Moment.
Alter YouTube
Deutschland, was ist hier wieder los?
Intro Video
wirklich minimalst
Intro Video hier.
Das da.
How to Dockerize in 7 easy
Steps.
Das ist 11 Minuten
und hat alle Basics von
installieren bis Docker Compose drinne.
Aber es wäre gut,
wenn man vielleicht ein bisschen vor Erfahrung
hat.
Wenn die Container auf Docker
hat, überprüft. Ne. Es gibt ein paar
offizielle
Container von den Projekten.
Aber ansonsten
kann dir da
einer den übelsten Müll
unterschieben.
Also nur dadurch, dass
man Container Sachen verwenden, wird die Sache
weitem nicht sicherer.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn man bei Ubuntu
China Paket
Repos hinzufügt oder so.
Benutzt du
Docker Compose in einer Prot Umgebung?
Nein. Also bei mir daheim ja,
auf der Arbeit nicht.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit generell wenig Docker.
Bei uns ist mittlerweile
eher so mehr Kubernetes Orchestrierung.
Wir haben also einen Server,
der mir jetzt sofort aus dem
Kopf
einfällt, wo wir Docker drauf haben,
ist eine Kiste,
die
da läuft CentOS drauf.
Aber wir haben mal eine Software eingekauft,
die braucht
eine spezielle PHP Version
und die gibt es nur
unter Ubuntu LTS 1804
glaube gerade.
Ne auf 20.04.20.04
die ist neuer, als CentOS hat.
Deswegen haben wir dort quasi
einen Ubuntu im Docker Container,
wo das drauf läuft.
Aber sonst haben wir relativ wenig.
Und es ist auch kein Docker Compose,
ein Stück normal hier, Docker Run
und gut ist.
Red Star OS machen wir nicht.
Ne, ich habe die Software schon ausgeschaltet.
Doch, habe ich, ich habe hier.
Klar, ich habe doch mal
einen Pastebin.
Hier Pastebin.
Ups, hier, den Pastebin.
Einfach eingeben gleich.
Den Pastebin, da ist die
Konfig drauf.
Die ich vorhin
auch rein Copy Pasted habe.
So Leute, ich muss jetzt
aber echt ins Bett.
Machts gut, wir sehen uns.
Nächster Stream, bis denn.
CU.
Brauchen wir Autromusik?
Chat, brauchen wir Autromusik?
Machts gut, bis denn.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.